bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 24h Sénat au
sommaire de l'actualité du Sénat
aujourd'hui le projet de loi sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
République avec dans un instant la
discussion générale sur ce texte nous en
reparlons bien sûr à 19h dans le journal
présenté par Delphine Girard et avant de
rejoindre tamtranui dans l'hémicycle je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
Gérard Colomb le sénateur socialiste
dénonce des contradiction dans le projet
de loi autant moi je suis pour un couple
métropole région autant je seraiis en
désaccord sur le fait que les régions
aient un pouvoir quasi exclusif sur
l'économie c'est méconnaître comment
aujourd'hui fonctionne notre économie de
la connaissance qui suppose évidemment
un réseau important d'univers
universitaires de chercheurs de start-up
de grandes entreprises et c'est à partir
de là que se crée une richesse qui est
ensuite redistribuer à tout le
territoire voilà et nous rejoignons donc
Tam trè nuit dans l'hémicycle th c'est
une discussion générale fleuve qui
s'annonce et oui effectivement pendant
plus de 6 he les orateurs doivent se
succéder à la tribune les orateurs qui
doivent venir défendre leur point de vue
personnel venir défendre le point de vue
de leur groupe leur point de vue des él
local il faut dire qu'ici au Sénat et
bien la colère gronde il faut dire
qu'après une première partie de la
réforme celle sur la carte des régions
où et bien le Sénat a été globalement
balayé rappelons qu'il y aura bien 13
régions et non 15 régions comme le
réclamer la haute assemblée et bien les
élus craignent qu'il en soit exactement
de même sur cette deuxième partie de la
réforme territoriale partie qui porte
elle sur les compétences des territoires
alors le nouveau Sénat de droite à
travers sa commission a donc proposé sa
sa propre version du texte avec des
modifications de taille avec la
suppression de la clause de compétence
générale mais aussi un rôle très
important accorderé au département alors
que le gouvernement avait quasiment
annoncé sa suppression il y a encore
quelques mois le Sénat va lu lui voir
les attributions sociale la solidarité
territoriale ve lui voir donner et bien
la gestion des collèges et encore bien
d'autres choses enfin et bien il reste
toujours ce débat autour des
intercommunalités avec ce seuil fixé à
20000 habitants voilà un sujet sur
lequel et bien les élus de la Haute
Assemblée ne sont pas d'accord bref le
Sénat est remonté pourtant tame le
gouvernement a tenté de lâcher du l'est
ces derniers temps sur le texte oui et
on a pu d'ailleurs l'entendre tout à
l'heure dans l'émicycle à travers le
discours de marielise rebrranchu la
ministre de la décentralisation qui est
intervenue pour dire son attachement au
Sénat pour faire un geste envers la
Haute Assemblée toutefois en restant
ferme sur les objectifs du gouvernement
il faut aussi reconnaître d'autres
gestes de l'exécu
par exemple sur le seuil des
intercommunalités sur le rôle des
départements manuel Vals était venu
exprèsétait déplacé au Sénat pour dire
son ouverture au dialogue sur ce sujet
enfin il faut rappeler et d'ailleurs
Gérard Larché le président du Sénat l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure que ce texte
était tout d'abord inscrit à l'ordre du
jour début novembre et puis Gérard
Larché a eu rendez-vous avec François
Hollande avec Manuel Vals et ensemble
ils sont tombés d'accord pour donner
plus de temps au sénateurs pour préparer
le texte texte qui n'arrive donc
qu'aujourd'hui au Sénat c'est encore une
ouverture de dialogue de la part de
l'exécutif mais enfin on le sait des
paroles aux actes des promesses aux
réalisations on connaît la chanson merci
Tam tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle pour la discussion
générale la séance est
reprise l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion générale du projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la République mais je
suis saisi d'une demande de rappel au
règlement exprimé par madame la
Présidente han Assassi vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement à trait à l'organisation de
nos travaux rarement débat parlementaire
n'aura démarré dans une telle confusion
nous débutons cet après-midi la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
nouvelle organisation territoriale
déclaré en procédure accélérée pour
reprendre donc la discussion des
amendements le 13 janvier prochain ce
qui en soit ne permettra pas une bonne
visibilité une bonne compréhension de
nos échanges mais à mon sens ce qui est
très regrettable c'est la remise en
cause du droit d'amendement dont les
sénatrices et sénateurs les groupes
politiques sont victimes en effet le
délai de dépôt d'amendement pour la
séance publique a été fixé à l'ouverture
de la discussion générale alors que la
Commission réunie mercredi dernier
jusqu'à 22h15 a adopté 166 amendements
modifiant considérablement le texte pour
l'immense majorité des sénateurs qui
n'assistaiit pas à la commission des
lois il est donc à ce jour
particulièrement difficile d'avoir une
vision précise de l'évolution de ce
texte ces nombreuses modifications
entraînent forcément une modification de
la lecture potique
du projet de loi les réunions de groupe
qui se tenaient ce matin même ont dû
réexaminer ce projet de loi préparer de
nouveaux amendements réajuster les
interventions générales en fonction du
déroulement de ces réunions relevait
tout bonnement de
l'impossible j'ai demandé comme d'autres
le report du délai de débau d'amendement
au début du mois de janvier pour
permettre un travail parlementaire au au
travail parlementaire de s'effectuer
dans de de bonnes conditions on m'a
répondu que la loi organique imposait le
début de la discussion générale comme
dernier terme pour déposer les
amendements alors je vous le dis très
respectueusement mais assez fermement
une erreur a été commise la complexité
du nouveau texte car il faut parler de
nouveau texte exigeit donc de reporter
l'ouverture de la discussion générale au
13 janvier prochain pour laisser au
Sénat un temps minimum de réflexion et
pour éviter de légiférer dans la
précipitation précipitation vous le
savez bien nuisible à la qualité de la
loi future la nouvelle organisation de
la République ne vous pouvait-elle pas
demander une journée supplémentaire de
débat en janvier pour être débattu avec
sérieux et sérénité j'ai été par
ailleurs choqué d'entendre en commission
que le que la clôture du délai
d'amendement ce mardi donc 16 décembre
ne posait pas de problème puisque
gouvernement et commission conserve le
droit d'amendement à tout instant cette
remarque met en exerg l'atteinte
profonde au droit d'amendement qui est
un droit individuel appartenant à chaque
sénatrice et à chaque sénateur c'est
également une façon d'indiquer sans
délicatesse que vous que si vous ne
souteneez pas le gouvernement et donc ne
pouvez espérer le soutien d'une
commission vous ne pouvez plus influer
sur la rédaction du texte logiquement
cette conf cette confusion sur un plan
formel lié à des conditions de débat
exécrabl 520 à amendement examiné en une
journée par la commission des lois
entraîne maintenant une confusion sur le
fond du texte et non sur la forme quel
est l'objectif du texte quel est son
champ d'action oui comme cela a été dit
en commission le risque est grand
d'assister à la création d'un d'un
véritable monstre juridique enfin
monsieur le Président la confusion
provient également des incertitudes
financières alors que les ressources des
collectivités territoriales vont être
sabrées de 28 milliard en 3 ans le débat
sur le projet nôre arrive comme si de
rien n'était ce débat est donc confus et
même pour une bonne part excusez-moi du
terme mais un petit peu virtuel pour
conclure monsieur le Président je
constate que l'une des raisons de cette
confusion actuelle provient de sa
limitation à un débat de spécialistes
pour ne pas dire de technocrate un grand
débat national devrait avoir lieu pour
écouter les attentes de la population
une telle pratique démocratique sans
doute permettrait sans doute de
clarifier les enjeux et de simplifier
les solutions monsieur le Président
pourquoi ne pas avoir reporté le début
de la discussion générale au 13 janvier
prochain pour permettre un bon travail
législatif au
Sénat monsieur le président de la
commission des lois vous vous avez
souhaité intervenir monsieur le
Président je vous remerci madame et
monsieurs les les ministres mes chers
collègues je voudrais apporter à notre
collègue iian Assassi quelques
précisions je voudrais tout d'abord
rappeler que évidemment à la commission
des lois dont vous êtes l'un des membres
éminents nous sommes particulièrement
soucieux de la qualité des débats et du
temps nécessaire pour que cette qualité
soit effectivement au rendez-vous je
voudrais vous rappeler toutefois que la
commission des lois a désigné dès le
mois de juin peu après l'adoption par le
Conseil des ministres de ce projet de
texte le 18 juin
dernier un rapporteur en la personne de
Monsieur René vanirendong dont j'excuse
l'absence aujourd'hui et que depuis juin
nous sommes en décembre nous avons tout
de même eu un certain temps pour
réfléchir à l'évolution nécessaire de ce
texte dont beaucoup d'entre nous ont
souhaité qu'il soit remis
d'appelon un second rapporteur le
président Jean-Jacques yest a été
désigné par la commission des lois dès
le mois de d'octobre dernier et nous
avons eu à l'initiative du président du
Sénat un débat avec le Premier ministre
le 28 octobre dernier c'est dire que
nous avons eu la chance sur ce texte et
c'est d'ailleurs assez exceptionnel dans
la préparation d'un débat parlementaire
d'avoir à la fois beaucoup de temps
entre l'adoption de ce texte par le
Conseil des ministres et le débat qui
s'ouvre maintenant et un certain nombre
d'éclairages qui était d'autant plus
nécessaire que nous avons pu avoir
légitimement le sentiment d'un certain
flottement de la part du gouvernement
sur les axes essentiels de la réforme
qu'il avait lui-même adopté alors notre
commission des lois éclairé par euh ces
deux rapporteurs qui je tiens à le dire
ont fait l'un et l'autre un travail tout
à fait considérable c'est fortement
mobilisé pour l'examen de ce texte
effectivement jeudi dernier à
22h30 après avoir examiné tous les
amendements qui étit euh inscrit euh à
l'ordre du jour de notre réunion euh la
commission des lois a adopté le texte
qui est le point de départ de la
délibération qui commence aujourd'hui
dès le lendemain matin le jeudi le texte
était en ligne et le samedi matin le
rapport était disponible ce sont des
délais qui peuvent paraître courts entre
jeudi dernier et le délais limite de
dépôt des amendements mais ce sont des
délais qui résultent tout simplement
d'un texte qui s'impose à nous tous
c'est le texte de la loi organique prise
pour l'application des articles 341 39
et 44 de la Constitution et ce texte
dispose dans son article 13 que les
amendements des membres du Parlement
cessent d'être recevables après le début
de l'examen du texte en séance publ le
début commence maintenant il n'y a eu
aucune espèce de distorsion dans la
procédure suivie pour préparer ce débat
et par conséquent je crois que nous
sommes obligés que nous en soyons
pleinement satisfaits ou non euh de
discuter sur la base des travaux euh de
la commission euh et il n'appartenait ni
à la commission ni euh je crois au
président du Sénat de rouvrir un délai
de dépôt des amendements qui est
déterminé par la Constitution et la loi
organique merci monsieur le Président un
mot madame la Présidente
euh je voudrais rappeler que ce texte
était
inscrit le dans la semaine du 3 novembre
et que euh c'est à la suite d'une
rencontre que j'ai eu avec le président
de la République et le Premier ministre
que nous avons convenu euh d'un
calendrier qui a certes quelques
inconvénients mais qui a eu l'avantage
de nous permettre d'entendre le Premier
ministre le remettre en perspective et
de profiter d'ailleurs des réunions euh
des trois associations représentant euh
les communes les départements et les
région que nous avons d'ailleurs réuni
en conseil national euh il y a quelques
jours et et donc sans m connaître mais
le respect de la loi organique est tel
que l'article 13 s'impose à nous d'utant
qu'il a été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc je pense que c'est
bien sûr une contrainte mais en même
temps ça a été une manière je fais une
rime pauvre une manière de desserrer les
trintes voilà donc je pense que nous
pouvons rentrer dans nos discussions
générales et je dois dire que le
gouvernement a tenu sa parole et
l'engagement qu'il avait pris à l'égard
du président du Sénat je voulais le
rappeler au début de cette discussion
générale donc maintenant dans notre
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Marie Lise Lebranchu ministre de
la décentralisation et de la fonction
publique Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE madame la
ministre merci euh monsieur le Président
Larcher merci d'avoir rappelé aussi ces
entretiens que vous avez eu avec le
Premier ministre qui ont permis un
déroulé effectivement qui peut-être
n'est pas satisfaisant mais a pris en
contre un maximum de demandes monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
monsieur le président de la délégation
au collectivité territorial monsieur le
rapporteur jeanjcques guè permettez-moi
salut amical à monsieur le rapporteur
René V direndong et mes vœux de promte
rétablissement Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapport pour avis Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs c'est
toujours un privilège pour moi pour
André Bini de se retrouver dans cet
hémicycle afin de défendre un projet de
loi concernant les territoires de France
les débats que nous avons eu tant au
cours de mes déplacements que devant
votre commission des Lois ont démontré
notre souhait commun de réussir cette
réforme et le Sénat y aura largement
contribué
nous
avons bien sûr échangé avec le Premier
ministre vous le rappeliez à l'instant
monsieur le le président et tant le
président de la République que le
premier ministre nous ont demandé de
trouver un maximum d'accord tout en
respectant bien sûr l' vie de
l'Assemblée nationale les travaux de
gouvernement ont toujours été très
attachés à suivre du Sénat en effet
c'est grâce aux États généraux du Sénat
de septembre 2012 que nous avons créé un
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
installé le 3 juillet dernier c'est à la
suite de ces mêmes états généraux que le
gouvernement a soutenu la proposition de
loi sur le statut de l'élu qui sera
bientôt j'allais dire enfin voté
définitivement et c'est dans le rapport
de Monsieur rafarin et kratinger que
nous avons puiser cette idée d'une
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique même si ce n'était pas le même
mot qui a été voté dans la loi
précédente je pense aussi aux
initiatives qui ont été effectivement
inscrites dans le texte comme dans les
textes comme la diminution des syndicats
locaux proposés par Monsieur mzard ou
celles qui ont été déjà introduites par
la loi la décentralisation du
stationnement payant ainsi que les pôles
d'équilibres territoriaux et ruraux
suggérés par la commission du votre
commission du développement durable la
compétence de gestion de l'eau et des
inondations issu du rapport des
messieurs andiani et Colomba à propos de
l'organisation territoriale de la
République l'étape d'aujourd'hui doit
nous permettre de redire le sens de
l'action publique du 21e siècle et
depuis les
décentralisations des les lois pardon de
décentralisation de Gaston de fer les
textes successifs n'est pas Monsieur
Jean-Pierre souur ont généré de très
bonnes avancées mais aussi de nombreuses
structures les centres de décision se
sont multipliés l'action publicque c'est
parfois complexifié notre débat doit
donc nous conduire à adapter ces
structures aux attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens car même si ces attentes
résultent d'injonction contradictoire
moins de dépenses publiques plus de
servicees publics elles nous oblige ces
structures ne correspondent pas
suffisamment aux réalité vécu elles ne
permettent plus de résorber les
inégalités ni de porter les services
publics nécessaires à nos concitoyens
nous n'acceptons pas que l'hyper
richesse côtoie l'hyper pauvreté et dans
trop de territoires urbains ou ruraux
les élus relaent un véritable sentiment
d'amandon non mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est bien là que se trouve
l'enjeu retrouver le sens de l'action
publique rendre l'organisation de la vie
quotidienne plus facile donner de
meilleures chances à nos concitoyens de
maîtriser leur avenir et celui de leurs
enfants leur donner l'envie de
s'impliquer davantage d'être des
citoyens engagés plus impliqués plus
concernés donc plus engagé et
reprendront le chemin du collectif et de
l'attention aux autres plus confiant il
reprendront le chemin des
urnes chaque Français doit se sentir
bien vivre mieux et être accompagné là
où il habite il doit pouvoir travailler
à un temps acceptable de transport de
son lieu d'habitation et s'il n'a pas de
travail il doit être accompagné dans sa
recherche d'emploi comme dans sa
formation nous devons toujours avoir en
tête ceux qui se sentent abandonné de la
promesse républicaine ceux qui n'en
peuvent plus d'attendre que leur pays se
redresse pour en retrouver la fierté
ceux qui se perdent dans le repli sur
soi quand ce n'est pas dans le rejet de
l'autre nous croyons à la force de notre
pays et nous avons confiance en nos
élus pour réussir monsieur le Président
de la Commission des loi vous avez
raison nous devons mettre fin à la
concurrence la concurrence n'est pas une
valeur elle est un fait et c'est par la
coopération que nous devons y répondre
par la coopération entre nos territoires
parce que la coopération est une valeur
la concurrence crée la complexité et
gaspille la dépense publique celle du
dumping territorial opons en lui une
saine coopération qui donne à chaque
territoire des fonctions à assumer des
responsabilités apporté la France est
comme un patchwork magnifique de
territoires différents la coopération
c'est le fil qui tient le tout et il est
temps d'en finir avec les rivalités
inutiles entre les teroire parfois entre
les élus rivalités qui font perdre de
l'énergie faire perdre du temps à tout
le monde et montrons aux Français que
les élus savent s'entendre savent
travailler ensemble dès lors que
l'intérêt général est en jeu leur
passion c'est l'intérêt
général si nous passons de la
concurrence à la coopération alors nous
sauverons la parole la parole publique
qui s'exprime dès ce moment c'est déjà
le sens de la loi précédente changer
d'approche reconnaître la diversité de
nos territoires adopter l'action
publique à cette diversité dans notre
pays il arrive qu'à seulement 30 km de
distance les paysages change
l'architecture change la cuisine ou
encore l'accent sont différents sans une
action publique qui prend en compte
cette diversité nous serions incapaes de
résorber les inégalités et de mettre fin
aux injustices dans les métropoles dans
les quartiers défavorisés dans les
villes moyennes dans les villages à la
montagne dans les territoires
ultramarins au côté de chacune et de
chacun de nos concitoyens
reconnaître des spécificités ce n'est
pas avantager certains territoires par
rapport à d'autres c'est justement leur
permettre de se développer au regard des
atouts et des besoins qui sont les leurs
pour les métropoles et les grandes
villes c'est assumer la responsabilité
de la recherche de la santé comme de
l'accueil des étudiants et des apprentis
cela sert bien évidemment les
territoires euros pour les territoires
euros c'est assurer l'indépendance
alimentaire de la France et de l'Europe
indépendance en danger quand disparaît
en 10 ans l'équivalent d'un département
au terre agricole mais c'est aussi dans
ces territoires euros porter
l'innovation la créativité et de
nouvelles filières économiqu chaque
territoire a son identité il faut la
préserver il faut l'enrichir ni la
fusion de région ni la fusion d'autres
collectivité n'y portera jamais atteinte
de la diversité réaffirmée à la
cohérence l'organisation territoriale de
la République doit refaire société et
porter progrès de la démocratie ceci est
d'autant plus nécessaire
que la clarification et le renforcement
des compétences locales doivent aller de
paire avec des contrepouvoirs forts
sinon nous aurons le risque de voir
s'accentuer le fussé entre l'action et
l'opinion publique si comme le suggère
Paul Valerie un état est d'autant plus
fort qu'il peut conserver en lui ce qui
vit et agit contre lui alors si nous
voulons des collectivités fortes nous
devons pouvoir en faire des espaces de
débat éclairés de débat transparents de
débats contradictoires la vivacité
démocratique de nos territoires ne se
décrète pas elle n'est pas facile à
écrire de même que la réalité des
pouvoirs de l'assemblée délibérante
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif d'une région ou
encore la limite des pouvoirs de
l'opposition néanmoins il n'est pas
impossible que quelques parlementaires a
des idées fécondes en la
matière la diversité démocratique de nos
territoires c'est aussi celle de nos
communes 36000 communes 36000 points
d'accès à la démocratie 36000 repère
pour nos concitoyens en ces temps
complexe la commune est un échelon
essentiel et un échelon d'évidence c'est
pourquoi le projet de loi que je
présente avec André Vallini a vocation à
la préserver en lui donnant la force du
regroupement je ne suis pas la ministre
des idotorialistes et des singtang
libéraux de ceux qui proposent dans tous
les tabloïdes de déchirer au plus vite
des départements ou de balayer des
communes au contraire avec ce projet de
loi nous permettons aux communes de
répondre à leurs difficultés grâce à
l'intercommunalité dans la droite ligne
de la proposition de loi commune
nouvelle que vous avez voté hier notre
texte garantit les communes il est un
formidable outil pour unir sans
détruire demain il n'existera plus de
communauté de communes fortes sans
intercommunalité fortte les communes
trop petites ne peuvent assumer toutes
les missions aujourd'hui attendues des
collectivités territo par nos
concitoyens nous entendons les élus nous
dire que la réforme territoriale pourut
remettre en cause la proximité je pense
au contraire et bien d'autres avec moi
qu'il ne faut pas confondre proximité et
morcellement car du morcellement au
recul des services publics il n'y a qu'
pas cette question du recul des services
publics est essentielle c'est là que se
joue à mon sens à notre sens notre plus
grand défi collectif car les extrémismes
sise dans les failles de l'action
publique l'intercommunalité permet de
repenser la présence physique de la
puissance publique sur nos différents
territoires ainsi grâce au projet de loi
notre les EPCI pourront définir des
obligations de service public nos
maisons de services publics doivent se
bâtir vite nous en fixons un objectif de
1000 pour commencer pourquoi parce que
il faut faire attention à ne pas tout
confier au numérique même si une
transition numérique peut également
apporter des solutions je dis une
transition numérique car c'est une
transition choisie qui refuse de verser
dans l'unanimisme ba du
digital parce que plutôt pardon que de
dématérialiser la présence physique des
pouvoirs publics sur nos territoires
l'outil numérique doit à l'inverse
permettre de la renforcer et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs nous avons pris en
compte les travaux d'ivrom et de son
group groupe de son groupe de travail
transpartisan mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous le constatons tous chacun
d'entre nous au sein de nos
territoires partout où nous sommes nous
savons que
l'intercommunalité c'est là où les gens
vivent où ils habitent où ils
travaillent il est temps de faire en
sorte que les limites de notre
organisation ne soit plus jamais pour
eux une barrière de
complexité pour se faire il faut trouver
l'échelle institutionnelle à même de
représenter les territoires vécus il
nous faut donc franchir un palier
supplémentaire installer la coopération
intercommunale au niveau
approprié c'est ce que nous pourrons
faire avec l'objectif de 20000 habitants
qui devra sans aucun doute sans aucun
doute monsieur mesard qui vous agacit
pouvoir être
modulé pourvoir être pouvoir être
modulé en fonction de la densité
démographique en fonction des temps de
déplacement en fonction des frontières
naturelles ou même des frontières
nationales le gouvernement proposera de
préciser au cours des débats que nous
allons avoir les aménagements possibles
au regard de ces critères sachez que je
serai sur cette question très attentive
au proposition que vous pourrez formuler
et je vous ai je me suis engagé hier
auprès du président de la commission des
lois a apporté en début janvier ce qui
fera circulaire pour nos préfets dans
l'application que vous de ce que vous
aurez ici proposé c'est à Michel Mercier
pardonnez-moi que j'avais proposé ça
hier
après-midi il était
rapporteur je dis je dis bien attends en
tant que
rapporteur le projet de que nous vous
présentons avec André Vallini redéfinit
donc le rôle aussi du département c'est
départements sont recentrés sur leurs
enjeux de
solidarité solidarité territoriale dont
l'aide au projet de territoire
l'ingénierie qui manque beaucoup trop à
trop de communes trop de communautés de
communes aujourd'hui qui ne peuvent
répondre aux diverses manifestations
intérêt solidarité envers les personnes
pour lesquelles cette réforme doit être
l'occasion de repenser les financements
je pense en particulier à celui des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
qui fait un vrai débat en France en ce
moment même les régions quant à elles
avec leurs compétences nouvelles leurs
forces porteront davantage progrès et
anticipation garante de l'avenir de nos
concitoyens et de nos territoire elles
devront permettre une meilleure
répartition de l'activité
elles agiront pour les citoyens ceux qui
cherchent un emploi qui vivent dans un
territoire en reconversion ceux qui
cherchent à se former et chacun doit
savoir quelle que soit sa situation que
sa reconversion et son avenir sont
assurés sur les questions d'emploi de
formation de développement économique
des territoires le Sénat a fait des
propositions du doute qu'elles viendront
alimenter fertilement nos
discussions à propos des structures
d'accompagnement le gouvernement a
entendu le message de la commission des
lois et partage l'idée selon laquelle la
région chef de fil des politiques de
formation d'orientation professionnelle
doit être renforcé et doit être plus
impliqué cependant compte tenu de
l'urgence dans laquelle notre pays se
trouve face au chômage il pourra être
dangereux de déstabiliser un système
qu'il faut d'abord et avant tout mieux
faire fonctionner sur les territoires
nous partageons ces insuffisances et le
constat d'insuffisance il faut donc
clarifier les domaines de compétences de
l'État et des régions et préciser leur
modalité de coordination ce n'est pas au
président Larcher que j'apprendrai que
cette question est aussi essentielle que
difficile à
régler les régions nous les voulons
espace de partage pour l'avenir de nos
territoires ainsi nous pourrons
promouvoir un nouveau modèle de
développement et assurer la transition
énergétique ce sont nos régions qui vont
travailler à l'anticipation économique
et l'émergence d'idées nouvelles elles
interviennent dans trois domaines
essentiel l'économie le transport la
formation
elles assurent la responsabilité des
aides directes et des entrées au capital
des entreprises
elle coordonne elles conduiseent pardon
le schéma régional de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation des entreprises
qui doit bien évidemment se conjuguer
avec les autres territoires en
particulier les métropoles et les
communautés
d'agglomération et comme rien ne se fait
sans cohésion le schéma régional
d'aménagement et de développement
durable du territoire permettra d'être
attentif à l'équilibre des territoires
et à la solidarité avec les territoires
en déprises dont on ne parle pas
suffisamment enfin chaque jeune aura les
moyens de préparer au mieux sa vie
future parce qu'il aura accès à une
formation de qualité c'est le sens du
transfert des collèges qui je le sais
fait ici grand
débat chaque conférence territoriale de
l'actionent publique doit répondre par
exemple à la question des cités
scolaires chaque conférence territoriale
de l'action publique doit pouvoir
répondre aussi à la question des
transports scolaires et nous n'avons pas
créer cette instance pour qu'elle devent
inutile les régions pourront enfin par
des contrats
infrarégionaux accompagner le volet
territorial des contrats de plan la
gestion des fonds européens qu'elles
assument aujourd'hui pleinement j'ai
bien entendu les remarques d'un certain
nombre de grandes villes et je sais
aujourd'hui que accord peut être trouvé
facilement pour ce partage des
responsabilités mais aussi cette
confrontation des idées et des projets
au sein de la conférence territoriale de
l'action publique que nous avons créé
nous pouvons maintenant supprimer la
clause de compétence générale pour les
régions et les départements conjuguant
ainsi efficacité et clarté avec échange
et confiance changer d'avis quand on
change d'avis de façon éclairée c'est un
honneur mais je n'oublie
pas de rappeler une de nos propositions
structurantes l'adaptation du pouvoir
réglementaire que nous avons abordé hier
au cours de débat concernant par exemple
l'urbanisme ou la gestion de l'eau que
nous devrons aussi garder pour la une
question aussi importante que celle du
tourisme qui j'en ai eu cette impression
ne fait plus partie du développement
économique mais ça c'est un
sourire Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la République porte de
grandes ambitions pour notre pays pour
la qualité de vie de nos concitoyens et
l'avenir de nos territoires c'est un
devoir pour nous gouvernement et élu de
la République que de la réussir c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faudra apporter
une attention particulière à la période
de transition et ce dans l'ensemble de
nos territoires la phase de transition
ce n'est pas une phase d'attente ou
d'attentisme bien au contraire c'est une
phase de
construction réussir la réforme c'est
aussi accompagner les agents publics ces
hommes et ces femmes qui font vivre nos
services publics les agents publics
travaillent pour nous tous au quotidien
ils nous soignent nous éduquent nous
orientent nous attendons de
l'exemplarité et l'incarnation de nos
valeurs républicaines à nous d'incarner
les employeurs irréprochables à la
hauteur de l'enjeu assonciant les à nos
réformes nous le leur devons la réforme
territoriale va emporter pour eux des
conséquences importantes des
conséquences pour leur quotidien qui
pourront aller certes seulement pour
quelques-uns jusqu'à des mobilités c'est
pourquoi le projet de loi leur apporte
des garanties quant à leur situation
personnelle conservation de leurs
emplois de leur niveau de ération de
leur protection sociale
complémentaire au-delà cette réforme
doit aussi conduire à donner un nouveau
sens à leur mission et conforter leur
engagement dans l'intérêt
général réussir la réforme enfin c'est
au-delà de la question institutionnelle
réfléchir vous avez raison à la question
des moyens je sais que cette question
nous interroge tous c'est bien normal je
sais qu'elle est source d'inquiétude
aussi dans de nombreux territoires mais
cela doit se faire dans un cadre où les
solidarités sont renforcées les charges
réelles des collectivités mieux prises
en compte et les investissements
d'avenir encouragé c'est pourquoi depuis
2 ans la péréquation a été garantie et
amplifiée par la DSR et la DSU et ce
grâce aux mesures du PLF les territoires
les plus pauvres contribuent fois moins
que les plus riches à la baisse des
dotations c'est une œuvre de
justice dans les de années à venir une
réforme de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement nous permettra de
conforter ce mouvement en renforçant la
transparence et l'équité en encourageant
la mutualisation et en prenant en compte
la spécificité des territoires nombreux
sont ceux au sein de cette Assemblée à
réfléchir à ces questions pense à
Monsieur Dalier ou monsieur Guéné qui
ont déjà apporté contribution
enfin nous soutiendrons les
investissements locaux
d'avenir je pense aux espaces publics
complément Indis indissociable de la
construction de logement aux équipements
publics rendu indispensable par la
démographie croissante de nombreuses
communes de France plus de crèches des
classes supplémentaires et de meilleurs
transport public en conclusion revenons
à notre ambition fondamental au soir du
vote la question qui devra se poser à
vous à nous ne sera pas qui a fait
quelle réforme la question qui devra se
poser sera at-on améorer la vie de nos
concitoyens a-t-on renforcé les
solidarités at-on permis à ceux qui
n'ont rien d'être accompagné par la
puissance
publique alors soyons
optimistes nous pourrions peut-être même
faire la dernière réforme d'organisation
de nos
territoires mon rêve dirait monsieur
deig partager je n'en doute pas par tous
les élus de la nation c'est que
l'organisation territoriale ne soit plus
un sujet de débat tous les 5 ans parce
que cela ralentit l'accent public elle
ne sera pas un sujet de débat tous les 5
ans si elle est adaptée à la réalité de
nos territoires et à la vie des gens
elle ne sera plus un sujet car nos
structures et notre droit auront
conjugué la souplesse et la
confiance avec la société du contrat
nous installons celle de la confiance
entre l'État et les collectivité entre
les tenants de l'exécutif et les élus
territoriaux entre les élus
eux-mêmes si nous pouvions avec cette
loi avoir permis à tel citoyen de
réaliser son projet à un autre de
retrouver un emploi à un autre de sortir
de la précarité à un autre encore
d'accéder à la culture et la créativité
à un jeune enfin de connaître
l'émancipation
et à nos territoires de ne plus compter
de territoires abandonnés alors oui nous
pourrions être fiers de nous de notre
travail de votre travail de ce que nous
avons fait pour la République et pour la
France je vous
remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole maintenant va être à
monsieur Jean-Jacques yest rapporteur de
la commission des lois
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs pour avis mes
chers collègues ah c'était formie dame
madame la ministre c'était vrai
c'était on aurait cru que tout était
bien et tout allait bien c'était
formidable on a évité les sujets qui
fâchaient qui fâch c'était bien bon mais
au moment où nous commençons à débattre
en séance publique du projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la République moi j'ai
participé à une loi qui s'appelit
administration territoriale c'était plus
modeste maintenant c'est nouvel
organisation vous me permettrez d'avoir
une pensée pour le corapporteur de ce
projet René Viren donc empêcher
provisoirement pour raison de santé qui
s'est fortement investi dans cette
réforme et avec qui j'ai pu travailler
en confiance et une communauté de vision
de la décentralisation c'est important
comme vous pourrez le constater à la
lecture de notre
rapport une telle approche et sans doute
au Sénat et pas
ailleurs et je ne citerai qu'un autre
exemple qui est pour nous une référence
c'est le rapport rafarin
crating qui a conforté nos
réflexions avant de vous faire part des
proposition de la commission des lois
presque tout adopté
unanimement qu'il me soit permis
d'évoquer le contexte de cette réforme
voulue par le gouvernement les principes
qui ont semblé le guider
et elle nous a paru un peu improvisée
parfois et les réflexions qu'elles ont
suscité nous sommes le 18
juin
2014 le gouvernement dépose deux projets
de loi l'un sur la délimitation des
régions l'autre qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui nous avons tous
déploré que les deux textes ne fassent
pas l'objet d'une discussion commune et
il reste bizarre pour tout esprit à peu
près bien constitué qu'on examine le la
forme avant le
fond décrétant la nécessité de grandes
région de taille européenne on a vu que
c'était pas exact sans même évoquer
leurs
compéten nous savons bien que l'onon
Leon serait en permanence en plein
paradoxe puisque confié aux régions des
compétences stratégiques
peut difficilement se marier avec
l'intention de faire remonter des
compétences de
proximité et c'est pourtant le contenu
du projet de loi qui poursuivant la
chasse au myth du millefeuille
territorial nous resserre la thèse du
rapport àali baladure et quelques autres
esprit
supérieur faire disparaître à terme les
départements
oui oui mais c'est un esprit supérieur
il y en a d'autres à droite comme à
gauche mais c'est eux qui nous disent
toujours ce qu'on doit faire faire
disparaître à terme les départements au
profit des régions et des
intercommunalités tout en dévitalisant
les communes dont le seul tort avec le
département est d'être une institution
qui qui est enracinée profondément dans
notre
République au nom de
l'efficacité mais pas de la dé
locale de soi-disant économie possible
on a entendu des chiffres mirfiques des
milliards des dizaines de milliards
d'économies à attendre le texte
d'origine avait pour but avoué
d'évaporer selon certains le département
en lui retirant toutes ses compétences à
l'exception de ses attributions en
matière sociale pour les confier aux
région à l'autre bout de la chaîne on
veut imposer de grandes
intercommunalités de 20000 habitants au
minimum qui auraiit pour ultime mission
de remplacer le département dans ses
fonctions sociales il faut peut-être
faire beaucoup plus de 20000 dans ce
cas-là et de faire de communes des
coquilles quasiment ves chargé de l'état
civil peut-être de la police municipale
des cimetières et sans doute de la
gestion des écoles belle ambition de
simplification vous l'avourz que je
caricature à
peine et qui transparaît clairement dans
l'étude
d'impact dont on ne peut dire qu'elle
nous apporte quelques arguments
pertinents t en matière de coûte que de
rationalité on semble oublier ce qui a
été au cœur de notre réflexion à savoir
le principe de
subsidiarité ce que l'on défend à
Bruxelles et on a raison ne serait-il
pas encore plus vrai à l'échelon de
notre pays et je pourrais en citer
quelques exemples mais je me contenterai
d'un parmi
d'autres le projet de loi transfère la
compétence des transports scolaires à la
région qui désormais devra organiser le
transport des élèves vers le plus petit
des regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux à 300 km peut-être au
pire 300 km de distance le paradoxe est
qu'en région
île-de-fance en région
île-de-fance le syndicat des transports
vîle-de-fance qui a le
monopole des transports interurbains et
scolaires s'est empressé de déléguer au
Département de la grande couronne
écheton de proximité pertinent les
transports
scolaires le pragmatiste est toujours
plus pertinent que la théorie dans ce
domaine comme dans beaucoup
d'autres vous avez sans doute noté par
ailleurs que le projet de loi n'est
n'est en aucune sorte porteur d'une
étape de la
décentralisation comme l'ont
été les lois du 2 mars 82 loi cadre
fondatrice qui a été décliné ensuite
dans de nombreux textes dont celui du 7
janvier 83 sur les compétences
ou celui du 3 du 13 août 2004 sur la
liberté responsabilité locale dit
loirfarin et que la réforme est
déséquilibrée en ce qu'elle n'apporte
aucune
indication sur la réforme de l'État
territorial et je vous renvoie notre
rapport sur ce
sujet sans doute peut-être au cours des
débat monsieur le secrétaire d'État
chargé de la réforme de l'État et de la
simplification pourrait utilement nous
éclairer sur les intentions du
gouvernement dans ce domaine en ce qui
en ce qui nous
concerne nous vous proposerons des
avancées en matière de décentralisation
mais j'y reviendrai et nous aurions
préféré que le gouvern prennent aussi
des initiatives en cette matière et
oui comme quoi quelquefois quand on
entend tout ce qu'on a
entendu selon l'endroit où on se place
certains voudraient faire des avancées
mais les services ne veulent pas les
services ne veulent pas et qu'est-ce que
fait un bon ministre il suit ses
services ou il leur dit maintenant ça
suffit et ben voilà c'est toute la
question mais c'est pas nouveau c'est
pas nouveau ah oui il faut être juste
depuis le 18 juin
2014 que de paroles ont été prononcé et
il semble que le gouvernement est
totalement changé de logiciel et
qu'après beaucoup de déclaration
contradictoire personne ne ve plus
évoquer la disparition programmée des
départements et des communes plus
personne ne veut en parler est-ce que
c'est sincère est-ce que c'est pas
sincère nous verrons bien la suite d'où
notre perplexité le projet de loi ne
correspond plus du tout à la déclaration
du Premier ministre devant le Sénat en
octobre
dernier
don d'autant que les grandes
associations d'élus ont reçu quelques
assurances et il faut saluer ici les
conclusions de la conférence des
collectivités local réuni à l'initiative
du président Larcher le 9 décembre
dernier qui rassemblait l'Association
des maires de franceassociation des
départements de France l'Association des
régions de France elles ont convenu de
porter une voie commune les attentes des
collectivités locales c'est nouveau et
le dialogue est quand même indispensable
dans ce
domaine et apprécié outre la situation
financière des collectivités locales et
la question des
normes la conférence a insisté sur la
nécessité de voir le projet de loi
enrichi par de nouvelles
décentralisations qu'il clarifie les
compétences des collectivités locales
entre elles et les sour afférente mais
aussi de clarifier la manière dont
l'État assure à l'avenir ses propres
compétences si le législateur n'a pas
être le greffier des désidératas des
associations d'élus
innombrables et chacun alors avance ses
pions pour savoir qui sera le plus fort
le plus gros au détriment des autres
dans des rivalités de pouvoirs assez
futiles alors qu'il s'agit seulement de
défendre l'intérêt général cette
conférence marque une étape important
dans la perspective d'un dialogue
constructif privilégiant d'ailleurs la
concertation sur les rivalités de
pouvoir le contrat sur l'affrontement
l'État pourrait s'en inspirer dans ses
relations avec les collectivités
locales face à un projet
désarticulés que
faire que faire vous savez que faire
c'est c'est PHAs
célèbre nous nous non je faisais je
faisais allusion à autre chose bon nous
vous proposons de le reconstruire sur
des bases plus solides et
pérennes prolongeant la clarification
des responsabilités et des compétences
par l'approfondissement de la
décentralisation cela passe par le
maintien des compétences des
départements dans un souci de proximité
et
d'efficacité et nous conduit à conforter
les compétces stratégique des régions et
à leur attribuer une compétence en
matière d'emploi à renforcer les
intercommunalités en tenant compte de la
spécificité des
territoires et à renforcer la
responsabilité financière des
collectivités locales ce que vous
proposez bien entendu nous aurons à
délibérer à nouveau de divers aspects de
la loi du 27 janvier
2014 de modernisation d'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles
nous avions bien dit que fallait encore
un petit chemin et même peut-être un
long chemin pour régler un certain
nombre de problèmes dans cette loi dite
maptam mais à ce stade la commission des
lois a voulu vous présenter un texte
clair
cohérent qui ne soit pas comme souvent
un catalogue de divers dispositions
concernant les collectivités locales et
quelques autres sujets annexes que nous
aurons tout loisir d'examiner au mois de
janvier sans vouloir entrer dans le
détail du prof du projet profondément
remanié que la commission des Lois vous
propose et il faut associé bien entendu
les rapporteurs pour avis Madame Valérie
dard pour la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur René Paul Savari
pour la commission des affaires
sociales Madame Catherine main Deli pour
la commission de la
culture monsieur Rémi Po pour la
commission du développement durable et
même monsieur Moret s'exprimera
également pour être plus sûr que le
point de vue de la Commission soit bien
entendu Charles gunet pour les
finances ses points de vue largement
convergent l'objectif principal a été
pour nous de clarifier les compétences
sauf pour celles t le tourisme la
culture et le sport où cela n'a guerre
de
sens la suppression de la clause de
compétence générale des régions et des
départements pr alors tout son sens car
l'efficacité de l'action publique
territoriale est largement conditionnée
par une meilleure clarification des
compétences à cet effet nous souhaitons
que soit affirmée la compétence de la
région en matière de développement
économique et nous sommes d'accord sur
ce point avec le projet de loi sans
ignorer les compétences économiques des
communes intercommunalités métropole sur
le plan opérationnel et d'aménagement du
territoire mais le rôle moteur de la
région dans ce domaine doit être
accompagné d'une véritable association
des autres collectivités dans la
démarche de planification pour la mise
en œuvre des schémas et d'ailleurs
Madame le Ministre on réunit beaucoup de
schémas parce que dans un seul ça serait
peut-être
suffisant pour assurer la cohérence de
l'action économique et de l'aménagement
du
territoire mais le plus important à nos
yeux et dans la perspective d'une
avancée en matière
descentralisation
nous a fait comprendre qu'il était
paradoxal de renforcer les régions en
matière de développement économique et
d'aménagement du territoire de lui avoir
confié la totalité de la compétence en
matière de formalité de formation
professionnelle et qu'elle soit absente
totalement dans le domaine de
l'accompagnement à
l'emploi avec notre collègue Savari que
je salue pour le travail pour qu'il a
effectué
et dans les limites permises par la
procédure
législative nous vous proposons de
confier aux régions un rôle important de
coordination dans ce domaine c'est
l'article 3 B de du texte de la
commission des lois pour les
départements et d'ailleurs on pourra
peut-être approfondir aussi d'autres
sujets de
décentralisation comme nous risquerions
de nous ennuyer pendant les faites si
nous ne travaillons pas nous allons
pouvoir peut-être monsieur le
président faire quelques autres
propositions pour les départements ah
ben les commissions peuvent pardon si
nous convenons que le transport
interurbain interurbain doivent être de
la compétence de la région nous
affirmons le rôle de proximité en
réaffirmant le rôle comme vecteur de
solidarité territoriale et de la
cohésion sociale reconnaissant
l'expertise et la bonne organisation de
cette collectivité en matière de collège
de route de port pour qu' en fait
envisager de les dépesser et de dépesser
ce qui en fait sa solidité et son
équilibre en ce qui concerne les
intercommunalités notons tout d'abord
que la loi de 2010 s critiqué alors par
ceux qui aujourd'hui voudrait nous
imposer un nouveau chambardement
rappelez-vous mais c'est normal hein ça
fait partie du
jeu la loi 2010 vient à peine d'être
mise en œuvre
désormais et conformément au souhait du
législateur je par pas la je parle pas
des lois ultérieur la lo 2010 désormais
conformément au SO du législateur toutes
les communes appartiennent à une
intercommunalité en
France faut-il à nouveau tout tout
bouleversé avec un seuil qui n'a aucune
justification aucune et peut adapt à la
diversité des territoires on pour battre
en infini il y en a qui disent 20000 il
y en a qui disent 15000 il y en a qui
disent 10000 on recommence mais ça ne
sert à rien ce que nous proposons c'est
de reporter d'abord d'Ant la clause dite
de revoyure c'est pas très beau mais ça
comme ça s'appelle comme ça inscrite
dans la loi en tenant compte des limites
urbaines des bassins de vie et des
scottes ce qui peut amener dans certains
cas que ça soit plus de 20000 dans
certains cas c'est moins de 20000 tout
dépend des territoires nous sommes donc
favorable à une rationalisation des
périmètres des EPC à fiscalité propre
mais sans multiplier les mariages forcés
comme on veut le faire en île- de-
France
oui ah oui ça oui he c'est quand même
bon oui oui oui oui oui oui hein et même
on casse des intercommunalités qui
viennent d'être créées après ce long
débat après un long débat et après avoir
adopté 166 amendements quand même le
texte donc on a retenu beaucoup d'AM nos
collègues le texte élaboré par la
commission des lois a été construit
autour de deux orientations
conformes à la
constante persévérance du Sénat dans ce
domaine je vous y rend attentif il vise
d'une part à préserver au sein d're
organisation territoriale les
compétences de proximité du département
que le projet de loi voulait transféré
aux autres niveaux de collectivité dans
l'intention affichée d'une disparition
des conseils généraux maintenant
départementaux à l'horizon 2020 d'autre
part dans l'objectif de clarification et
de cohérence des compétences d'évolue à
chaque niveau de collectivité
renouant avec l'ambition
décentralisati dont ce texte éta
initialement
dépourvu en tant qu'assemblée
législative assurant la représentation
des collectivités territoriales de la
République nous souhaitons vraiment être
entendu
non pas par peur du changement ou par
conservatisme mais parce que nous
croyons profondément à la République
décentralisée encore faudra-t-il mais
nous ne pouvons traiter à ce stade vous
avez évoqué ces sujets madame la
ministre réformer profondément non
seulement la DGF mais l'ensemble des
finances locales qui sont devenus un
Maqui impénétrable et de toute façon
pour les départements le poids des
dépenses sociales F fond
ils peuvent plus tenir de toute façon
c'est pas en le retirant des compétences
qu'on arrangera leur situation la baisse
des dotation ne peut être la seule
réponse de l'État à l'inquiétude
croissante et légitime des élus locaux
mais comme l'écrivait une des
personnalités endendu par la
commission nous devons tracer une route
sans sans sous-estimer les obstacles
juridiques et
financiers rappelant que la réforme de
80 2 a mis 30 ans à être pleinement
appliqué et que celle de 2004 ça savait
à peine notre ancien collègue
yvcattin craignait qu'à vouloir aller
trop vite c'était prendre le risque de
bloquer la machine et de perturber
l'activité des collectivités locales je
pense que c'est une réflexion qui doit
être méditée avant de tout casser il
faut peut-être progresser dans la
sagesse habituelle du
Sénat merci monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Valérie lettard
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques vous avez la
parole ma cher collègue merci monsieur
le
Président Monsieur le Président
euh madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission des lois ch
cher Jean-Jacques yest à qui j'associe
bien sûr ré virendon comme vous l'avez
rappelé qui est malheureusement
souffrant et peut ne peut-être avec nous
et et bien sûr moi aussi j'aurais une
petite pensée pour lui et pour le
travail énorme qui a été mis en place
par la commission des lois et ses
rapporteurs d'audition qui nous a
beaucoup beaucoup éclairé mes chers
collègues rapporteurs des autres
commissions mes chers collègues je viens
vous présenter l'analyse et les
propositions de la Commission des
affaires économique qui a décidé de
centrer son approche sur deux volets de
ce projet de loi l'économie et le
tourisme en tant que rapporteur pour
avis j'aiété frappé par la diversité des
points de vues qui se sont exprimés au
cours des auditions cela m'a convaincu
que l'amélioration de l'efficacité des
interventions économiques ne pourra être
réellement mise en œuvre que si les
projets et schémas régionaux sont
rassembleurs c'est-à-dire élabor
conjointement et programmé dans le
détail seulle cette
coélaboration permettra de préserver la
motivation des élus mais aussi le
réalisme territorial qui sont les deux
moteurs du succès des interventions
économiques des
collectivité tel est le message simple
qui ordonne les propositions de la
commission des affaires économiques la
réforme ne doit pas être guidé par un
esprit de système mais par l'analyse
concrète des transformations économique
et des risques pour la cohésion sociale
qui planent tout particulièrement sur
certains territoires j'ajoute que la
situation actuelle ne nous donne guerre
le droit à l'erreur pour mémoire je
rappellerai que les interventions
économiques des collectivités
territoriale avoisine 6,5 milliards
d'euros c'est-à-dire le 7e de celle de
l'État et 0,3 % du
PIB les régions il consacrent 2,1
milliard d'euros les établissement
publics de coopération intercommunale
1,7 milliard d'euros les départements
1,6 milliards d'euros et les communes
983 millions cela représente une part
limitée du budget des collectivités 8,3
% pour les régions 1,6 pour les
départements 1,7 pour les
intercommunalités et 1,5 pour les
communes sur la période récente les
dépenses d'intervention économique des
collectivités ont progressé de près de 1
% par an en moyenne cell des
départements ont décru tandis que les
interventions des régions ainsi que des
communes et leurs groupements à
fiscalité propre ont augmenté sur le
plan institutionnel le cadre juridique
des interventions économiques des
collectivités a été redessiné par deux
lois de décentralisation récente la loi
du 27 février 2002 relative à la
démocratie de proximité a institué le
rôle de chef de file de la région ce qui
impose la nécessité d'obtenir l'accord
de la région pour une collectivité
infrarégionale qui souhaite créer un
positif propre la loi du 13 août 2004
relative aux liberté et responsabilité
locale quant à elle a supprimé la
distinction entre aide directe et
indirecte pour adapter le droit français
aux exigences de l'Union européenne en
pratique cette disparition des aides
indirectes libre s'est traduite par une
augmentation du nombre d'aidees à
l'immobilier que les collectivités
peuvent octroyer sans accord de la
région nous connaissons tous sur nos
territoires le résultat actuel de ce
Maqui institutionnel à l'heure où les
contraintes budgétaires se font toujours
plus pressantes il est grand temps de
rendre l'intervention des collectivités
la plus efficace possible c'est ce souci
d'efficacité qui a guidé la réflexion de
la commission des affaires économiques
et je la résumerai en trois idées forces
première idée force nous devons
consacrer le rôle de chef de fil des
régions en matière de développement
économique dans une logique de cohérence
et de simplification afin d'éviter les
doublons c'est une certitude ce rôle de
coordination doit être spécifié car le
développement économique est une
politique publique qui fait intervenir
de très nombreuses dimensions les
régions sont par exemple à bonne échelle
pour organiser les plateformes de
projection des PME ou des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire à l'export ou
encore pour coordonner les stratégies
d'attractivité l'organisation des
grandes filières industrielles
régionales dans le contexte mondialisé
que nous connaissons ces actions doivent
impérativement être coordonné pour
optimiser la visibilité de nos
territoirees deè idée force nous devons
permettre la prise en compte des
spécificités des territoires par une
association forte de ceci à
l'élaboration des schémas régionaux et à
leur mise en œuvre il s'agit donc
d'encourager le dynamisme des
collectivités au moment où notre pays en
a le plus fortement
besoin il s'agit au-delà des cœurs de
métiers des régions le soutien du
développement économique qui là du
développement économique qui passe par
de nombreux vecteurs sur lesquels les
régions n'ont ni monopole ni véritable
capacité de maîtrise d'ouvrage je veux
parler ici de l'animation de proximité
de l'économie locale tel que réseau
d'affaires interface territoriale entre
université monde économique aménagement
économique du territoire immobilier
foncier dépllution des sols réseau les
Services Support aussi nécessaires pour
attirer des entreprises logement offres
culturell et sportives ou encore les
crèches le nouveau périmètre des régions
risque encore de faire perdre en
proximité en imposant une distance plus
grande entre le niveau régional et
certaines communes ou
intercommunalités on voit bien dans ces
conditions que si le schéma de
développement économique doit être
réfléchi au niveau régional il doit
aussi être coconstruit et coproduit avec
les autres acteurs du territoire en
particulier le niveau des
intercommunalités et des métropoles qui
sont compétentes en ce domaine trè 3è
idée force nous devons introduire dans
la loi la souplesse nécessaire à
l'élaboration de schéma qui soit
vraiment du cou humain en bref nous
sommes favorables à des métropoles
dynamiques qui soient des locomotives
d'un développement régional équilibré
pour se faire il nous faut clarifier les
registres d'intervention entre le bloc
communal et le niveau régional tout en
respectant le principe de libre
administration des collectivités locales
et l'absence de tutelle de l'une sur
l'autre ces idées forces m'amènent à
vous préciser les principaux amendements
qui découlent de cette analyse pour
surmonter tout risque d'incertitude
juridique tout en nous conformant à la
logique économique et sociale nous
proposons une solution simple et
réaliste à l'article 2 du projet de loi
l'élaboration conjointe des schémas de
développement économique c'est en
travaillant tous ensemble que les
régions et leurs territoires
infrarégionaux pourront construire des
politiques qui allient à la fois l'aide
au tissu économiqu existant et la
préparation des activités du futur c'est
pourquoi les orientations du schéma
doivent être mises en bat au sein des
conférences territoriales de l'action
publique pour un avis global je vous
proposerai également d'articuler ce
mécanisme avec le recours à la
contractualisation prévu dans le droit
existant depuis la loi d'affirmation des
métropoles matpam à travers la signature
de convention territoriale d'exercice
concerté il s'agit de clarifier la mise
en œuvre des orientations du schéma et
de définir l'implication des
collectivités dans une
territorialisation fine l'objectif vous
le comprenez madame monsieur le ministre
il n'est pas d'opposer un niveau à un
autre mais bien ni même d'ajouter une
certaine lourdeur dans les processus
d'élaboration de ces schémas bien au
contraire il s'agit de mobiliser toutes
les énergies autour d'un projet commun
cohérent efficace une vraie vision
stratégique régionale de grandes
filières qui définiront quelque chose un
consensus partagé mais qui ne peut
trouver son sens que si
contractuellement les territoires
peuvent face à une région qui est bien
évidemment pilote dans ce grand avion et
bien définir avec précision quelle sera
la traduction de ce schéma régional dans
chacun des territoires intercommunaux
pour que le levier soit le plus efficace
possible et que bien évidemment très
finement les stratégies soient adaptées
à la connaissance des territoires sur
cette réalité car vous le savez nombre
d'intercommunalités aujourd'hui sont
porteuses bien évidemment de ces
stratégies et font déjà ce travail
conjointement avec les régions je vous
rappelle par ailleurs que le débat qui a
eu lieu en commission des loi animé par
Monsieur yest a aussi rappelé combien
ces conventions pourraient être utiles
pour régler la question des métropoles
car aujourd'hui les métropoles bien
évidemment revendiquent pleinement leurs
compétences en matière économique et
voit bien des difficultés effectivement
dans la l'élaboration de ces schémas
dans lesquels nous nous souhaitons qu'
il n'y ait pas de poids de mesure un
schéma qui s'appliquerait à tout le
territoire sauf au métropole ça n'est
pas envisageable sinon on crée une
rupture d'égalité il faut les métropoles
englobé dans ce schéma mais en même
temps comprenons tous bien qu'une
métropole à qui nous venons de donner la
capacité à devenir un vrai levier une
vraie locomotive économique il faut bien
évidemment que l'élaboration de sa
stratégie comme pour tous les grands
EPCI qui aujourd'hui sont des relais de
développement économique des relais de
croissance économique par leur action
forte en lien avec le tissu économique
seront véritablement autant d'effets
démultiplicateurs pour une région qui
sera toujours pilote qui ne sera pas
dépossédé mais qui au travers d'une
organisation qui sera réfléchie portée
régionalement se verra véritablement
mise en œuvre avec l'intervention et le
soutien de tous et là les métropoles
peuvent venir dans un schéma régional
parce que là les métropoles pourront
aussi contractualiser et on le voit au
travers de cette proposition là nous
pouvons régler cet aspect sans mettre en
péril l'équilibre de maptam voilà les
deux principales modifications que je
souhaitais soumettre au Sénat je me
félicite que le texte adopté par la
commission des lois est pris en compte
ou satisfait partiellement 11 des 16
amendements que la commission des
affaires économiques avait approuvé
cependant je suis convaincu qu'il faut
encore améliorer le texte pour favoriser
la montée en gamme des schémas de
développement économique par cette
fameuse coconstruction et cette
contractualisation c'est d'ailleurs
cette même idée qui a soutendu les
amendements qui était présenté dans le
cadre de la commission des affaires
économiques sur la compétence tourisme
et je ne m'étalerai pas plus sur cette
question puisque la logique est la même
sous réserve de ces observations et de
l'adoption des amendements qui en
résultent la commission des affaires
économiques a approuvé l'adoption des
volets intervention économique et
tourisme du présent projet de loi je
vous remercie
merci madame le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur René Paul Savari
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur bien
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
madames messieurs les les les
rapporteurs je tiens bien sûr moi aussi
à remercier l'écoute que nous avons eu
d' cette commission des lois et tout
spécifiquement bien sûr les rapporteurs
de la commission des lois nous avons
fait un travail tout à fait intéressant
il appartenait à la commission des
affaires sociales de présenter le volet
action sociale des départements euh pour
faire des propositions qui ont
d'ailleurs été acceptées et nous avons
également profité pour essayer de bâtir
les premières étapes d'une
régionalisation de la politique de
l'emploi qui serait nous semble-t-il une
avancée majeure dans dans dans le
dispositif alors faut rappeler le
contexte effectivement qui a prévalu à
nos travaux à savoir que nous étions
dans une spirale très particulière pour
les départements lorsque ce projet de
loi a été élaboré et puis les esprits
ont évolué la mobilisation des élus
locaux a sûrement porté bref les
départements sont préservés les choses
sont claires maintenant mais à quel prix
madame la ministre je voudrais vous
témoigner notamment les difficultés
rencontrées par le personnel
départemental qui a été particulièrement
affecté euh par ce manque de
reconnaissance manifeste ça mérite
d'être souligné à nouveau me
semble-t-il la
notoriété la notoriété également des
conseils généraux
collectivité reconnue de
proximité de solidarité a été
sérieusement mise à mal c'est en tenant
compte de ce contexte
nouveau que nous avons examiné les
articles 23 et 24 du projet de
loi l'article 23 prévoit la possibilité
d'organiser dans le cadre d'une
convention le transfert ou la délégation
du Département vers la métropole de SEP
groupe de compétences dont six ont trait
à l'action sociale nous étions
particulièrement concernés dans sa
version initiale le texte disposait que
dans l'hypothèse où aucune convention
n'aurait été conclue sur au moins trois
des SEP groupes de compétences au 1er
janvier 2017 leur totalité serait
transférée de droit au métropole là
aussi madame la ministre où est la
cohérence si vous ne trouvez pas
d'entente pour trois compétences comment
imaginez qu'on imposit 7 va régler les
divergences aussi la commission des
affaires sociales a estimé que seul le
conventionnement volontaire devait
s'appliquer la délégation ou le
transfert doivent alors traduire
l'existence d'un projet de territoire
construit et pensé de façon conjointe
par le Département et la métropole ils
doivent en outre être circonscrit à un
nombre limité de compétences clairement
définies afin de pas créer de distorsion
avec le reste du territoire et pour
préserver la capacité d'organisation de
l'action sociale du département sur
l'ensemble de son territoire c'est le
sens des amendements que nous avons
porté et sur lequel sur lesquels nous
avons été rejoints par la commission des
lois à l'article 24 cet article qui
supprime la clause de compétence
générale des départements nous avons
réaffirmé là aussi les deux piliers sur
lesquels doit reposer l'action de ces
derniers à savoir la solidarité entre
les h et la solidarité entre les
territoires là aussi la commission des
lois a bien partagé notre position enfin
la commission des affaires sociales a
tenu à proposer une une solution
particulière à la question récurrente de
l'accueil et de l'accompagnement des
mineurs isolés
étrangers par la mise en place d'un
prélèvement sur les recettes de l'État
dont l'objet de compenser une partie des
dépenses à la charge des départements il
s'agit d'assurer
une
juste une juste répartition des
responsabilités de l'État au titre de
l'immigration et des départements au
titre de l'accueil des socials à
l'enfance nous espérons être suivi dans
cette
proposition à ce stade de mon
intervention je ne peux madame la
ministre que vous faire part de ma
frustration et oui le texte que nous
examinons constitue le véhicule
législatif idéal pour engager des
réformes structurelles concernant en
particulier l'accueil des jeunes enfants
la politique du logement les politiques
d'insertion d'accompagnement des
personnes âgées ou des personnes
handicapées rien de tel rien de tel dans
ce projet de loi et les marches de
manœuvre dont dispose dont dispose le
Parlement pour enrichir le texte sont
très limités en en effet les règles de
recevabilité financière des amendements
empêch empêche enveloppe de financement
même constante tout transfert de
compéten d'une d'une personne publique à
l'autre nous souhaitons mieux tous
rendre lisible l'action publique sur nos
territoirees mais passer d'une logique
de partage voire d'ench enchevêtrement
parfois à une répartition claire des
compétences nous fait prendre le risque
de contrevenir à la constitution c'est
quand même inouï pourtant plusieurs
mesures simples seraient à la fois gage
d'une efficacité accrue d'une
utilisation plus efficiente des données
publiques d'une meilleure lisibilité des
politiques menées pour nos concitoyens
et la bas elle est dans le camp du
gouvernement c'est pour cette raison
Madame la Ministre que je vous ai fait
parvenir une lettre dernièrement qui
vous proposer trois mesures
structurelles qui peuvent paraître tout
à fait intéressantes j'ai adressé
d'ailleurs le double à Monsieur monsieur
le le ministre concernant notamment le
le financement conjoint par l'assurance
maladie les conseils généraux dans les
Centre d'Action médicau Social sociau
précoces les cams d'autre part essayer
de faire un rapprochement entre les
maisons d'accueil spécialisés les masses
et les foyers d'accueil médicalisé à
double tarification mais également faire
en sorte que les maisons pour
l'autonomie et l'intégration des
maladies d'Alzheimer les Mayas soit de
compétenence départementale puisque
c'est un niveau en fait supérieur des
clics ce qui permettrait de mettre sous
la même collectivité la responsabilité
de tel de tel dispositif merci de
répondre merci de répondre à à mes
propositions si cela vous intéresse bien
sûr mais je suis sûr que ça vous
intéresse j'en viens maintenant à la
régionalisation de la compétence emploi
que la commission des affaires sociales
relayé par la commission des lois
introduit dans le texte qui vous a
présenté aujourd'hui comme vous le savez
ce sujet était totalement absent du
projet de loi initiale alors qu'il est
fortement attendu par un grand nombre
d'élus locaux et de sénateurs quel que
soit d'ailleurs l'orientation politique
en effet dès lors que la région est
compétente en matière de développement
économique d'orientation de formation
professionnel d'apprentissage pourquoi
ne pas aller au bout de la logique en
lui confiant également la compétence
emploi pourquoi ne pas faire confiance
aux régions qui sont l'échelon pertinent
pour piloter la politique de l'emploi au
niveau territorial à la proche des
bassins d'emploi et disposant d'une
vision stratégique
irremplaçable et c'est bien cette vision
stratégique que vous nous avez vendu
pour justifier le concept de grande
région pour essayer de me convaincre que
rein par exemple à tr/ d'heure de Paris
allait être sous l'influence
métropolitaine de Strasbourg al
maintenant si les régions n'ont pas la
compétence emploi à quoi sert ce grand
chambardement
c'est dans cet esprit d'ailleurs que
l'Association des régions de France a
proposé de transformer à titre
expérimental les régions en autorité
organisatrice d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi impliquant notamment un
transfert de crédit et des agents de
l'État l'amendement que j'ai proposé ne
va pas aussi loin puisqu'il pose
seulement les jalons de la
décentralisation de la compétence emploi
aux régions seul le gouvernement cont
tenu des règles de recevabilité
financière posé par l'article 40 de la
Constitution pour être plus ambitieux et
avant de vous présenter les apports du
texte de la commission je voudrais
dissiper d'emblé tout malentendu et
éviter toute polémique inutile nous
n'avons nullement remis en cause les
prérogatives de l'État en matière
d'élaboration en matière de pilotage ou
de financement de la politique de
l'emploi les critiques selon lesquelles
nous aurions méconnu le principe du qui
paye décide ne me semble donc pas
opérante nous n'avons pas davantage
contesté le rôle des services
déconcentrés de l'État en matière de
restructuration des entreprises et
d'inspection du travail enfin nous ne
modifions aucunement les règles
d'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
qui ont vocation à rester nationale au
final le texte de la commission renforce
le rôle de pôul emploi et de la région
afin de rationaliser le service public
de l'emploi le premier volet porte en
effet sur pô emploi afin d'en faire un
facteur incontournable de la politique
de l'emploi d'une part pô emploi devra
conclure des conventions pluriannuel de
coopération avec l'ensemble des acteurs
économies de la politique de l'emploi
puis présenter régulièrement des
propositions visant à réduire le nombre
de ces intervenants et à rationaliser
l'organisation du service public de
l'emploi ensuite les conseils régionaux
les conseils régionaux seront avant
consultés avant la conclusion de la
convention pluriannuelle nationale concl
conclu entre l'État pô emploi et
l'Unedic tandis que les régions pourront
bénéficier d'un siège supplémentaire
spécifique au conseil d'administration
de l'opérateur
public par ailleurs Paul emploi pourra
désormais acheter directement des
formations collectives si elle présente
un intérêt national défini par décret ce
qui permettra notamment de préserver
certains centres de formation de
rayonnement national de l'AFPA qui sont
actuellement menacé et qui inquiète
beaucoup de sénateurs le second volet le
second volet porte sur la région qui
aura à la charge d'assurer la
coordination des intervenants du service
public de l'emploi sur le territoire la
présidence du crfop le comité régional
de l'emploi de la formation et de
l'orientation professionnelle sera ainsi
confié au président de région et ne sera
donc plus partagé avec Monsieur le
Préfet de région
il faut un chef de fil une voix unique
pour éviter la cacophonie les luttes de
pouvoir et bousculer les
conservatismes madame la ministre mes
chers collègues comme vous le constatez
le texte de la Commission propose un
compromis sur cette question essentielle
de la régionalisation de la compétence
emploi c'est une base de travail pour
ouvrir le débat nous n'avons pas la
prétention d'avoir épuisé le sujet
certains estiment que l'on les règles du
jeu en en matière de de gouvernance des
créfop moins d'un an après leur création
par la loi c'est vrai mais ces comités
madame monsieur le ministre ces comités
des créfop n'ont même pas tous désignés
leur bureau il n'est donc pas trop tard
saisissons cette
occasion avant de conclure je voudrais
consacrer quelques mots à
l'accompagnement social vers l'emploi
nous devons absolument placer l'individu
au centre des politiques
d'accompagnement global sans se soucier
de savoir si le demandeur d'emploi
bénéficie ou non du Revenu de Solidarité
Active les actions d'insertion
demeureront de la compétence du conseil
départemental mais il faudra mieux les
articuler avec les missions du crfop
afin de conforter son rôle d'ensemblier
d'ensemblierier des politiques de
l'emploi au sens large à l'échelon
régional
et c'est bien à l'échelon
départemental d'organiser les missions
d'insertion et d'accompagnement social
vers l'emploi quel que soit le statut de
la personne encore faut-il encore
faut-il que les départements en aent les
moyens les finances départementales sont
exang du fait des dépenses non
maîtrisable non maîtrisable du Revenu de
Solidarité AC
dont le nombre de bénéficiaires continue
d'augmenter
inexorablement aucune plus-value n'est
générée par les départements concernant
le financement des rémunérations de ces
bénéficiaires dont l'instruction relève
de la CAF et les critères d'attribution
sont établis par
l'État quel
dommage quel dommage de ne pas avoir
saisi l'opportunité de ce projet de loi
pour clarifier les choses mes chers
collègues beaucoup de départements
seront en déficit comptable de
fonctionnement si des mesures concrètes
ne sont pas prises rapidement elles y
seront encore plus vite si rout si rout
et collèges sont transférés aux régions
ce qui accentuera la dstructuration des
budgets et précipitera les finances
départemental dans le
rouge en
conclusion maintenir les départs
bien les faire vivre c'est mieux créer
de vastes régions stratégi pourquoi pas
les rendre dynami c'est primordial je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur
rapporteur la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Catherine ma de
rapporteur pour avis pour la Commission
de la
culturez la parole ch collègu
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes très chers
collègues dans un contexte général de
crise économique profonde et durable de
désillusion quant à la portée de
l'action des pouvoirs publics chacun
s'accorde sur l'importance de simplifier
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays depuis quelques années plusieurs
textes ont ainsi été débattus et votés
au Parlement sans qu'il en résulte
réellement de partage du pouvoir de
décision ni clarification de ce point de
vue le projet de loi qui nous est
transmis aujourd'hui n'échappe pas à la
règle en effet ce n'est pas un nouveau
texte de décentralisation à proprement
parleré à vrai dire pour être pertinente
la réforme aurait dû intégrer un
préalable qui est la réforme de l'État
lui-même il est en effet difficile de
parler d'approfondissement de la
décentralisation sans que l'État n'ait
d'abord procédé à un examen rigoureux de
ces missions dans ce projet de loi il
n'est ainsi question que de répartition
de compétences entre collectivité
territoriale même si elle n'a pas
vocation à traiter de cette réforme de
fond dans son ensemble votre commission
de la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication ne pouvait rester absente
de ce débat elle s'est donc saisie pour
avis des dispositions du projet de loi
relative à la culture au sport ainsi
qu'à l'éducation sans oublier qu'il y
aura également une incidence forte sur
la vie associative mais à travers ces
compétences ce sont bien des enjeux
généraux qui se posent le projet de loi
qui nous est soumis ne saurait être
élaboré comme un texte désincarné sans
tenir compte des intérêts des publics
concernés je pense entre autres aux plus
jeunes de nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi
en matière éducative notre commission
s'est prononcé en défaveur du transfert
aux régions des collèges et des
transports scolaires elle a adopté deux
amendements visant à supprimer les
dispositions concerné des articles 8 et
12 du projet de loi dont je me réjouis
qu'ils aent été repris par la commission
des lois bien qu'étant à titre personnel
initialement sur le papier plutôt
favorable à ces transferts je me suis
efforcé d'en mesurer le bien faoné à
l'ône des des critères que sont la
lisibilité la proximité la cohérence et
l'efficience de l'action publique mon
premier constat est que la nécessité de
ces transfert n'est pas avéré sans pour
autant se satisfaire de l'existant la
commission aétienne la conclusion du
rapport de 2009 de nos collègues Yve
créting Yve crétinger et Jacqueline
gourau selon laquelle je les cite l'état
actuel de la répartition des compétences
apparaît comme globalement satisfaisant
une remise en question pourrait soulever
plus de difficultés qu'elle n'en
règlerait la répartition des compétences
en matière éducative est organisé vous
le savez selon un principe simple à
l'état la responsabilité de
l'enseignement aux collectivités la
prise en charge des conditions
matérielles de l'enseignement les
responsabilités des collectivités en
matière de fonctionnement des
établissements répondent à une logique
de subsidiarité les communes prennent en
charge l'enseignement primaire et les
départements les collèges tandis que les
lycées relèvent des régions la gestion
des collèges et des transports scolaires
constitue avant tout une compétence de
proximité notre commission considère peu
logique un tel transfert au profit des
13 grandes régions stratèges dont la
vocation est le développement économique
l'aménagement du territoire et la
planification des formations les
nouvelles régions se verrait ainsi
embarrassé du transport scolaire de 4
millions d'élèves et du fonctionnement
quotidien de
5271 collèges public en plus des 2513
lycées dont on voit mal en outre comment
avec ces élu elle assurerait le suivi
dans les conseils
d'administration le transport scolaire
constitue l'exemple même d'une
compétence aux enjeux complexes un tel
transfert ferait fit de l'expérience
acquise par les conseils généraux en la
matière l'interdiction de la
subdélégation madame la ministre tend à
créer un dispositif rigide totalement
inadapté aux enjeux je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le rapport Malville
Lambert exclu expressément les
transports scolaires des compétences à
transféré aux régions de plus
l'harmonisation des pratiques en matière
de tarification porte un double risque
celui d'un alignement sur le plus 10 an
au risque d'une dégradation
supplémentaire des finances local ou
celui d'une harmonisation par le bas qui
augmenterait nécessairement la charge
des familles autre point sur le plan
pédagogique chose très étonnante le
transfert des collèges aux régions
méconnaî les orientations fixées par la
toute récente loi de refondation de
l'école il il a guerre plus d'un an je
rappelle que cette loi organise la
continuité entre l'enseignement primaire
et le collège notamment par la création
d'un cycle de consolidation CM1 CM2 6e
et d'un conseil école collège où doivent
siéger les élus municipaux et
départementaux de fait les gains
attendus qu'il soit de nature financière
ou en matière de qualité du service sont
plus
qu'incertain à ce sujet je ne peux
déplorer je ne peux que déplorer
l'indigence de l'étude d'impact qui
conglue à des économies d'échelle sans
qu'aucun chiffre ne soit avancé les
auditions que nous avons mené ont abouti
hélas à ce constat en revanche ce
transfert s'accompagnerait certainement
de dépenses importantes lié à
l'harmonisation des politiques en
matière d'équipement ou de numérique
mais également au transfert des
personnels TOS à lui seul le coût de
l'alignement au mieuxisant des régimes
inddemnitaires s'éléveré à 120 millions
d'euros par an c'est donc pour cette ces
raisons que notre commission s'est
prononcé vous l'aurez compris contre ces
transferts j'en viens aux dispositions
du projet de lois relatives aux
compétences partagées qui sont je le
rappelle pour ce qui nous concerne
directement la culture et le sport dans
chacun de ces deux domaines les
collectivités territoriales jouent de
longue date un rôle essentiel chaque
année elles consacre plus de 7 milliards
d'euros à la culture et plus de 12
milliards d'euros au sport dont 2,9
milliards pour les seules
associations culture et sport ne
constiue pas une compétence obligatoire
mais les collectivités ont massivement
investi ce champ depuis 30 ans en se
fondant sur leur clause de compéten
générale les financements conjoints sont
importants même s'ils ne peuvent être
précisément évalués le monde de la
culture comme le monde le mouvement
sportif ils nous l'ont dit sont attachés
à cette pluralité de financement le
projet de loi ne revient pas sur la
clause de compétenence générale
concernant la culture ou le sport il
reconnaît même à l'article 28 le statut
de compét partagées il ne saurait s'agir
pour autant de figer un statut quo ce
serait nié la réalité d'un contexte
budgétaire très difficile des évolutions
vous le savez sont en cours qui se
traduisent par une répartition
progressive des rôles ne serait-ce que
parce que certaines collectivités sont
contraintes de faire les choix on notera
que dans le domaine sportif comme
culturel région inter commommunalités
sont amenés à être de plus en plus
impliqués s'il est trop tôt pour acter
précisément dans la loi une répartition
des missions par échelon c'est-à-dire
une véritable compétence répartie nous
devons engager la réflexion en ayant en
tête la structuration et la mise en
coréence des politiques concernées
l'efficacité de la action publique du
coup le service rendu à nos concitoyens
il faut encourager les collectivités à
s'organiser au plus près des ralité de
terrain par voie de
contractualisation notre commission a
d'ailleurs estimé que cela est
particulièrement vrai dans le domaine
des enseignements artistiques de
l'enseignement supérieur culturel et des
industries culturelles et créatives si
le projet de loi consacre donc la
compétence partagée il a aussi pour
ambition de simplifier son exercice en
présid en précisant le cadre de la mise
en place de guichet unique sur le papier
l'idée est évidemment séduisante et elle
s'inscrit dans le vaste mouvement de
simplification des démarches de nos
concitoyens en revanche en pratique qui
dit guichet unique dit concertation
approfondies en amont entre collectivité
et administration chacun de chacun
chacune pardonnez-moi devant logiquement
veiller à ce que la dimension de
l'action publique qui lui incombe soit
prise en compte je ne suis pas sûre
qu'au total il nen résulte pas une
suradministration et donc un frein à la
mise en œuvre des projets aujourd'hui
nous devons concilier deux
principes le principe constitutionnel de
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales et le principe d'une
responsabilité collective dans le
contexte général de crise des finances
publiques les collectivités sont de plus
en plus
contraintes de se désengager de nombreux
projet la ministre de la Culture vient
d'ailleurs de stigmatiser ses décisions
comme si ellees n'étit pas lié au moins
pour parti à la baisse des dotations de
l'État je le regrette je pense que le
devoir de l'État serait plutôt
d'accompagner les collectivités et de
veiller à ce que des pans entiers de la
culture ou du sport ne soi pas
abandonnés comme l'ont été cette année
les enseignements artistiqu ou à ce que
des territoires ne soient pas oubliés je
pense en particulier aux zones rurales
et péries urbaines à l'instant ma
collègue Valérie lettard a insisté sur
la prise en compte de ces territoires
par une association forte de ceuxci à
l'élaboration des schémas régionaux et à
leur mise en œuvre c'est important car
nous le sentons tous la montée en
puissance des métropoles et des régions
nourrit sur le terrain un sentiment
d'abondon des espaces qui en sont d'une
manière ou d'une autre exclus aux yeux
de nombre d'élus du monde rural ou
périurbain la culture le sport les
activités périscolaires c'est bon pour
les villes prenons garde à veiller à ne
pas nourrir ce sentiment source de
déséquilibre toujours plus grand entre
territoires urbains conquérant et
territoires ruraux abandonnés entre
pôles connectés gagnant et les autres ce
projet de loi madame la ministre doit
être l'occasion de veiller à corriger
les inégalités sociales et territoriales
en approfondissant les liens entre
démocratie et culture la commission de
la culture a souhaité confier ce rôle à
une instance créée par la loi matmanan
la conférence territoriale de l'action
publique car il nous paraissait
essentiel de ne pas ajouter une nouvelle
structure existante même si la question
de sa gouvernance mérite d'être discutée
en profondeur nous avons eu des débat
là-dessus en commission cela revient
bien sûr à la commission des lois nous
pensons que la CTA P doit être l'outil
pour un dialogue entre collectivités
territorial ainsi qu'avec l'État afin de
penser au mieux selon les territoires
l'exercice concerté des compétences
partagées nous nous réjouissons à ce
titre que la Commission des loi est
intégré au texte examiné aujourd'hui les
amendements que nous avions proposés il
précise que les commissions thématique
de la CTAP comprennent une commission de
la culture et une commission du sport il
confie la CTAP la mission de veiller à
la continuité des politiques publiques
dans les domaines de la culture et du
sport ainsi qu'à la mise en vre
équilibré de ces politiques dans
l'ensemble des territoires nous espérons
ainsi qu'avec la CTAP culture la CTAP
sport nous disposerons d'un outil
précieux de construction des actions
territoriales en définitive mes chers
collègues nous abordons l'examen d'un
projet de loi important
même si nous ne devons pas en attendre
plus qu'il n'a à offrir surtout entre
aujourd'hui et l'examen des articles les
métropoles seront mises en place preuve
de l'enchevêtrement entre structure et
compétences je ne suis donc pas sûr que
nos concitoyens y trouvent des raisons
de retrouver confiance en l'action
publique en tout cas par ces amendements
votre commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication
espère y avoir contribué et je souhaite
que nous puissions poursuivre
collectivement dans cette direction au
cours de nos débats mes chers collègues
je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci merci madame la
Présidente la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Rémy poinreau rapporteur
pour avis de la commission du
développement
durable
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues la commission du développement
durable et de l'aménagement du
territoire s'est saisie pour avis de 11
articles de ce projet de loi qui relève
directement de son champ de compétence
elle s'est ainsi intéressé à quatre
sujets les articles 5 à 7 qui renforce
la planification régionale les articles
8 à 11 sur les infrastructur et services
de transport l'article 14 sur
l'évolution de la carte intercommunale
et les articles 25 à 27 sur
l'accessibilité des services au public
et à l'aménagement
numérique avant de vous présenter la
position retenue par notre commission
sur ces sujets je souhaiterais formuler
quelques remarques d'intérêt général qui
résume l'esprit du débat qui s'est tenu
tout d'abord sur la force
cette réforme territoriale est menée
dans un désordre et une confusion
absolue les élus des zones rurales ne
comprennent pas l'enchaînement des lois
relatives à l'organisation de la
République mais les communes urbaines ne
le comprennent pas mieux il aurait sans
doute été préférable de réfléchir à une
loi cadre décliné ensuite dans d'autres
textes or l'approche qui a été retenue
est celle d'une fragmentation entre la
loi du 27 janvier 201 qui crée les
métropoles le projet de loi sur la
délimitation des régions dont l'adoption
définitive est imminente et le présent
texte sur l'organisation territoriale de
la République la première erreur nous la
connaissons a été de faire des
redécoupage avant de réfléchir à la
répartition des compétences en effet il
ne s'agit pas simplement de redessiner
une carte sur le coin d'une table entre
amis cette réforme n'est pas faite pour
les élus mais pour les citoyens pour
l'amélioration de leur quotidien le but
ultime est de faire en sorte que le
service qui leur est rendu soit de
meilleure qualité et coûte moins cher et
sur ce point la question du regroupement
des régions touche finalement peu les
élus de terrain en revanche l'évolution
des conseils généraux est un vrai sujet
car ce sont bien et souvent les premiers
part partenair de nos concitoyens les
conseillers et généraux sont très
inquiets s'agissant de leurs ressources
financières il est vrai que les communes
rurales sont habituées à la 10ette cont
tenu de la faiblesse de leur base
fiscale et de l'absence de cotisation
foncière des entreprises sur leur
territoire mais ce n'est pas pour autant
qu'il faut se satisfaire de l'absence
d'une étude précise des impacts
financiers de ce projet de loi notamment
pour les département et une telle
évaluation faisait déjà défaut je le
rappelle dans la loi du 27 janvier 2014
qui avait été muette sur les nouveaux
coûts supportés par les
intercommunalités il aurait donc fallu
définir dès le départ les ressources et
les compétences des régions avant de les
fusionner comment évoquer en effet la
puissance financière des régions si
elles n'ont pas plus de ressources la
fusion de deux régions n'augmentera pas
leurs moyens enfin l'engagement de la
procédure accélérée sur un texte de
cette importance n'est pas de nature à
favoriser un dialogue constructif et
apaisé et je regrette que la Conférence
des présidents de l'Assemblée nationale
n'ait pas suivie celle du Sénat pour s'y
opposer fermement j'en viens maintenant
aux remarques de fond puisque l'objectif
est de clarifier les compétences pour
renforcer l'efficacité de chaque
collectivité en mettant notamment ENF à
la clause de compéten générale encore
faut-il définir les missions avant de
décliner les compétences et le
Gouvernement sur ce point a fait le
Paris aveugle de renforcer les régions
et de confier l'exercice des compétences
de proximité tout d'abord aux
intercommunalités c'est ce qui était
prévu dans le texte avant d'envisager un
temps la la suppression des départements
à l'horizon 2020 ce qui ne semble plus
être le cas apparemment
en ce qui me concerne j'estime que cette
solution ne correspond pas à la réalité
des besoins ressentis sur le terrain des
missions précises se dessinent au Sénat
avec l'ensemble des élus qui ont
travaillé sur ce projet de
loi ainsi la commune pourrait être la
base de la démocratie de proximité et du
renforcement duun sociale le département
ét en lui le gestionnaire de proximité
qui garantit la la couverture en service
public et puis la région l'échelon de la
stratégie qui veille à l'accessibilité
du territoire en grande infrastructure à
la
réindustrial réindustrialisation à
l'économie et à l'emploi il faut
également veiller à bien garder à
l'esprit cette logique car elle
correspond à la manière dont s'expriment
les besoins les revirements successifs
du gouvernement ne sont pas de nature à
clarifier les choses
ainsi certains envisagent même de
confier la distribution de l'électricité
et de l'eau potable effectués de longues
dates par les syndicats au département
qu'on voulait supprimer il y a peu il
faut bien dire que les conseils généraux
sont les principaux perdants du projet
de loi et le département perd beaucoup
de compétences ce qui peut avoir des
pour effet pervers de faire apparaître
une forme de concurrence avec les
syndicat notamment
départementaux et cela donne aussi
l'impression que nous allons en mars
prochain é lire des conseillers
départementaux avec un scrutin binominal
dont on sait qu'il est un peu
surréaliste et qui n'auront plus de
compéten donc moins de travail et qui
seront finalement plus
nombreux d'une façon générale il en
ressort que l'ensemble de débats et
audition sur ce texte que les conseils
généraux souhaiteraient conserver
certaines compétences que les régions ne
semblent d'ailleurs pas demander et les
régions elles aspirent à certaines
compétences de l'État qui lui euh ne
veut pas leur déléguer ex nous sommes
ici un un certain nombre de sénateurs à
avoir imaginé que les régions et les
départements auraient pu fonctionner
comme les communes et les communautés de
communes nous aurions eu ainsi deux
couples oou l'instance inférieure douée
de compétence générale mutualiserait
dans l'instance supérieure ce qu'elle ne
peut pas faire
seule et puis une élection des
conseillers régionaux au second degré
comme autrefois aurait fait de la région
finalement une communauté de département
ce qui aurait évité pour le coup les
doublons l'architecture est bien sûr
actuelle et certes éloigné de cette
vision mais il faut au moins veiller
dans les zones rurales à ce que le
département reste le garant de la
cohésion sociale et des solidarités
territoriales il faut également faire
attention à ne pas renforcer
excessivement les intercommunalités en
zon rurales les élus locaux ont du mal à
les appréhander en zone périurbaines
elles ne sont parfois que les
décompressions des budgets des
villes-centres et leur domination
politique sur les communes périphériques
est souvent une réalité
n'oublions pas que les élus locaux
éprouvent toujours des difficultés pour
accepter des position ne recueillant pas
un large
consensus l'État veut également nous
obliger à mutualiser nos moyens entre
communes et intercommunalité pourquoi
pas nous le faisons déjà comme certains
fit la pro sans le savoir il faudrait
d'abord que l'État aussi donne l'exemple
sur ce point d'autes part le système qui
consiste à à répartir les dotations en
fonction du degré de mutualisation est
une est pour moi une abération nos
secrétaires de mairie en en milieu
rural coulent sous le travail
administratif de plus en plus
contraignant et je ne vois pas comment
on pourra porter une heure ou 2 heur
par-ci par là en terme de mutualisation
pour une autre commune ou une communauté
de commune ça sera très compliqué et je
crois que la mutualisation doit rester
libre pour s'adapter aussi au territoire
ainsi l'intercommunalité n'est pas la
réponse à tout associer 30 ou 40
communes pauvres ne fait pas une
intercommunalité riche et je ne crois
pas au mariage forcé à l'obligation et
même lorsque la corbeille est belle ce
n'est pas toujours le montant de la dote
qui fait le bonheur des communes le
seuil même si ça y contribue
le seuil des 20000 habitants
initialement prévu par le projet de loi
soulève une profonde inquiétude chez les
élus ruraux dans ces territoires il est
en effet difficile
d'atteindre un ensemble de cette taille
sauf à ignorer les distances et les
cooups induits et en zone urbaine en
revanche 20000 habitants c'est peu nous
devons donc sortir d'une logique
purement quantitative et privilégier une
logique qualitative
adapté aux réalités
territoriales en ce qui me concerne je
partage la vision d'une république au
plus près du terrain la seule réponse à
la complexité croissante de notre
société c'est la proximité il faut que
les compétences de proximité reste au
bloc local et il est essentiel de
remettre la commune au cœur du
dispositif le citoyen comprend tout ce
qui se passe dans la commune elle
constitue la base de la République et il
n'est pas possible de s'en passer on
bien là où veut nous emmener par la la
haute administration parisienne qui
envisage je dis tout gouvernement
confondu de faire élire un jour les
présidents de communauté de commune au
suffrage universel en en renforçant les
communautés de communes et puis de
supprimer un jour les communes on voit
bien que c'est c'est inscrit j'en ai
terminé avec ces considérations qui
expliquent la position retenue par la
commission du développement durable sur
chacun des sujets dont elle est elle
s'est saisie ainsi à l'article 6
concernant le schéma régional
d'aménagement et développement durable
du territoire nous avons adopté un
amendement supprimant l'obligation de
compatibilité des SCOT plu et charte de
parc naturel régional avec les règles
générales du facicule du strat nous
proposons ainsi de supprimer
l'obligation de compatibilité au
bénéfice d'une simple prise en compte en
considération
ou recommandation la commission des lois
n'a cependant pas retenu cette approche
et je le regrette nous menons tous et
j'y participe directement avec la
délégation collectivité territoriale à
une réflexion sur la simplification des
normes et il n'est pas souhaitable que
Le Strat puisse imposer des règles
territorialisées aux échelons inférieurs
des collectivité et nous devrons donc à
nouveau examiner cet amendement en
séance publique à l'article 7 sur les
modalités d'entrée en vigueur du strat
nous avons adopté un amendement
supprimant l'habilitation à légiférer
par ordonnance pour préciser le contenu
du schéma et clarifier sa portée qui
apparaît superflu au regard des
dispositions très détaillées de
l'article 6 les rapporteurs de la
commission des lois ont adopté la même
approche et je m'en félicite à l'article
8 qui concerne les transports routier
non urbain la commission n'a pas adopté
l'amendement de suppression que je lui
avais proposé nous avons eu un débat
très riche qui témoigne de la complexité
de ce sujet et sans aboutir à une
solution consensuelle nous sommes
parvenus à la conclusion que le cas du
transport scolaire est à part même s'il
n'est pas toujours facile de l'isoler du
transport
interurbain la commission des lois a
finalement choisi de ne maintenir que le
transport scolaire au niveau du
département il fallait trancher et je me
félicite qu'on soit parvenu à cette
solution de compromis je crois qu'il
faut aussi de la souplesse dans ce texte
par ailleurs nous avons souhaité la
suppression de l'article 9 qui prévoit
le transfert aux régions de laavirie
départementale la commission des lois a
également retenu cette solution de bon
sens ce qui témoigne du consensus qui
règne sur ce sujet à l'article 11 qui
concerne le transfert des ports
départementaux nous avons adopté un
amendement qui supprime la clause de
transfert par défaut des ports aux
régions en l'absence d'une autre
candidature au 31 mars 2016 l'objectif
était de privilégier au maximum la
concertation sous l'égide du préfet de
région plutôt que d'imposer
systématiquement un transfert à une
collectivité qui n'en voudrait pas cette
approche est toutefois dépassé par le
texte de la commission des lois qui a
privilégié la suppression totale de
l'article à l'article 14 nous nous
sommes prononcés en faveur d'une
suppression de la hausse du seuil
minimal d'intercommunalité à 20000
habitants
au profit d'une solution plus souple
laissant à la commission départementale
de coopération
intercommunale le soin de proposer un
niveau adapté aux réalités du terrain la
commission des lois a plus simplement
maintenu le droit actuel soit un seuil
de 5000 habitants en mettant l'accent
sur la nécessité d'achever en priorité
la dynamique engagée depuis 2010 et je
me range derrière la sagesse de cette
solution toujours à l'article 14 nous
avons adopté un amendement qui sans
remettre en cause l'objectif de
réduction des structures syndicales
remplace la notion de double emploi par
celle de la rationalisation des
compétences et des périmètres afin de ne
pas suggérer une concurrence stérile
entre les EPCI à fiscalité propre et des
syndicats la commission des lois a
cependant retenu une approche plus
radicale qui vise à faire disparaître
tous les syndicats jugés redondants en
privilégiant systématiquement les EPCI à
fiscalité propre il s'agit donc d'un
débat que nous devrons avoir aussi en
séance publique enfin à l'article 27
nous avons adopté un amendement qui
étant les possibilités de mutualisation
du financement des investissements
numériques cette solution a été retenue
par la commission des lois qui l'a même
complété dans un sens encore plus
favorable voilà rapidement présenter les
amendements adoptés par la commission du
développement durable dont une partie
figure d'ors et déjà dans le texte
adopté par la commission des
lois et je conclurai tout simplement en
insistant sur le fait que ce texte n'est
pas un texte de loi de décentralisation
mais de clarification avec la volonté au
départ de remplacer les départements par
les interc sauf que la réalité a dépassé
le gouvernement qui avec la création de
grandes régions ne peut plus supprimer
les département
pour des raisons de proximité mais
également juridique vous devez ainsi
madame la ministre faire contre mauvaise
fon fortune bon cœur et entendre et
approuver les amendements du Sénat le
véritable succès de la décentralisation
c'est d'avoir apporté à la République la
République au plus près du
terrain et en s'éloignant cet esprit et
bien on risque d'amplifier la défiance
de nos concitoyens à l'égard des
pouvoirs publics risque d'amplifier le
sentiment d'abandon qui règne surtout
dans la ruralité ce sentiment d'abandon
ai qui s'est traduit dans les dernières
élections européennes alors de grâce
même si ce projet de loi n'est pas le
nôtre faites vôtre madame la ministre de
nos propositions je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Charles
guet rapporteur pour avis de la
commission
des
finances vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président madame
et monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues tout d'abord je souhaiterais
bien
entendu féliciter l'ensemble de nos
collègues pour le travail qu'ils ont
réalisé tout particulièrement la la
commission des lois sur un texte aussi
complexe
couvert en qualité de rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances je
souhaiterais commencer par aborder ce
texte sous l'angle de ses conséquences
financières ce qui ne vous surprendra
pas ce projet de loi nous a été tout
d'abord présenté comme un moyen de
réaliser des
économies monsieur André Vallini
secrétaire d'État à la réforme
territoriale a ainsi annoncé en mai
dernier que la réforme territoriale
permettrait de réaliser entre 12 et 25
milliards d'euros d'économie ce chiffre
ensuite été revu à la baisse autour de
10 milliards d'euros pourtant l'étude
d'impact n'évalue pas n'évalue pas
précisément les économies attendu pour
sa part la commission des lois n'a pas
des Finances n'a pas partagé l'optimisme
du gouvernement en toute état de cause
des économies ne sont réalisables qu'à
moyen terme à court terme au contraire
les transferts de compétences envisagé
pourrai entraîner une augmentation des
dépenses comme beaucoup l'ont souligné
du fait notamment d'un alignement à la
hausse des régimes des personnels
d'ailleurs l'agence moodis a estimé en
juin dernier que les mesures proposées
ne généreront pas d'économie nett car
elles ne font que
redistribuer les coûts entre les
différents niveau de collectivité en
fait les dispositions financières sont
les grandes absences
de ce texte la réorganisation des
compétences proposées par le
gouvernement n'est accompagnée d'aucun
projet concernant l'allocation des
ressources aux collectivités
territoriales le cas des régions est
particulièrement frappant d'ailleurs les
concours de l'État représente 40 % de
leurs recettes de fonctionnement et ell
ne disposeent que de très faib marge de
manœuvre fiscal le Premier ministre
lui-même l'a admis il déclarait ici même
le 28 octobre dernier que pour que les
régions disposent des capacités à
investir elles devront être dotées d'une
fiscalité économique dynamique et adapté
à leur
mission on évoque ainsi souvent le
transfert d'une part de CVAE pourtant le
présent projet de loi ne comprend aucune
disposition fiscale il prévoit
uniquement que les transferts de
compétences entre les différents niveaux
de collectivité territoriale seront
compensés grâce à une dotation de
compensation versée par une colle une
collectivité territoriale à une
autre une commission locale d'évaluation
des charges et des ressources devra
évaluer les charges correspondant à
l'exercice des compétences transférées
ainsi les départements continueraient de
percevoir de la part de l'état des
ressources en contrepartie des
transferts de compétences passées mais
ils verseraiit eux-mêmes une dotation de
compensation au régions cette
disposition est calquée sur celle qui
s'applique à la métropole de Lyon
d'ailleurs mais elle est généralisée à
toute la France et pour despans entier
de compétences le département deviendra
une sorte de boîte aux lettres
bénéficiant des compensations de l'État
qu'il transférerait ensuite aux région
les finances locales en deviendrai
cononsant plus illisiblebles
encore en définitive ce texte n'apporte
pas de réponse aux questions financières
qu'il soulève la modification la
répartition des compétences et ses
conséquences sur la fiscalité ainsi que
les ajustements de la péréquation qui
s'avont indispensable auront pourtant
des effets considérables qui
nécessiteront la définition d'une
nouvelle
gouvernance en effet au cours des
dernières années
l'État a pu être tenté d'imposer aux
collectivités territoriales sa vision
des finances locales sans toujours tenir
compte de leurs contraintte
particulières tandis que pour leur part
rons an les collectivités territoriales
ont pu être tentés de se réfugier
derrière leur libre administration pour
s'extraire quelque peu de certaines
obligations nationales ces deux
attitudes ne sont plus possibles un
dialogue renouvelé entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales devra être
mise en place la solution du Haut
Conseil des territoires ét écarté l'an
dernier par le Sénat elle revient en
féigrane dans ce texte à travers le rôle
que le gouvernement souhaite donner au
Comité des finances locales ou à la Cour
des comptes il appartiendra à mon sens
au Parlement de se saisir de cette
question de formuler des propositions et
de définir sa place dans ce cadre la
Conférence nationale réunie il y a
quelques jours d'ailleurs par le
président du Sénat on est peut-être
l'esquiss la commission des finances s
saisie pour avis des articles 30 à 34
qui concernent les finances locales et
notamment la transparence financière
l'article 30 propose notamment que les
opérations d'investissement d'un montant
supérieur à un seuil fixé par décret
soit accompagné d'une étude relative à
leur impact pluriannuel sur les dépenses
de fonctionnement cette mesure doit être
considérée comme une aide à la décision
et non comme une contrainte
supplémentaire qui serait imposée aux
collectivités territorial il faudra
cependant veiller à ce que le seuil soit
calibré pour tenir compte de leur taille
à l'article le 31 la commission des lois
a supprimé des dispositions relatives à
la présentation par le premier président
de la Cour des comptes devant le Comité
des finances locales du rapport annuel
sur les finances locales et du rapport
relatif à la situation et aux
perspectives des finances
publ la commission des finances s'est
félicité de cette suppression dans la
mesure où elle ne voit pas de raison
d'institutionnaliser pour l'heure et au
bénéfice de ce que j'ai dit précédemment
un tête à-tête entre deux instances
chargées chacune à leur façon d'éclairer
le Parlement et le
gouvernement la commission des finances
s'est montré plus réservée sur l'article
32 qui prévoit que les collectivité
territoriale dont les recettes de
fonctionnement s'élèvent à plus de 200
millions d'euros peuvent participer à
une expérimentation de la certification
de leur comptees conduite par la Cour
des comptes dans la mesure il ne s'agit
que que d'une expérimentation reposant
sur le volontariat elle ne s'y est
cependant pas opposée toutefois la
répartition du coût de la certification
entre la Cour des comptes et les
collectivités territoriales devra être
précisé l'article 33 prévoit que la
participation financière des
collectivités territoriales aux
sanctions financières prononcé contre
l'État pour manquement au au droits
communautaires
ça vous interpellera certainement aussi
poser le principe d'une responsabilité
des collectivités ne semble pas absurde
mais le dispositif proposé comporte de
nombreuses limites le champ de la
responsabilité des collectivités
territorial n'est pas suffisamment
circonscrit et les conditions selon
lesquelles est arrêté la participation
financière des collectivités
territoriales ne leur offre pas
suffisamment de garantiese alors cont
tenu de ces diverses limites la
commission des finances a souscrit à la
suppression de l'article par la
commission des lois bien sûr si le le
texte avait subsisté n nous l'aurions
sans doute amendé ce sera peut-être une
chose à faire lors de la navette en tout
cas enfin l'article 34 quant à lui n'a
pas appelé de remarque particulière de
votre commission des finances en
définitive la commission des finances a
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption des
articles 30 31 32 et 34 tel qu'il
résulte du texte de la commission des
lois et a souscrit à la suppression de
l'article 33 suivant là
également l'excellent travail qu'a pu
réaliser la commission des lois j'en ai
terminé je vous remercie pour votre
attention mes chers
collègues bien mes chers collègu merci
monsieur le rapporteur ceci clos les
avis des rapporteurs pour avis
je dois dire que je vais maintenant
donner la parole sur le temps de leur
groupe à deux présidents c'est une
dérogation par rapport à la décision de
la Conférence des Présidents je je dois
le dire euh donc nous en reparlerons en
conférence des présidents je vais donner
la parole au président Hervé Moret pour
minutes je suis un bon négociateur quand
même
hein
pardon
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
rapporteurs j'ai souhaiter en effet
pouvoir m'exprimer en tant que président
de la commission chargée de
l'aménagement du territoire sur ce texte
car je considère qu'il impacte fortement
l'aménagement du territoire il faut
d'ailleurs remarquer que alors que nous
n'avons pas eu de loi d'aménagement du
territoire dans dans ce pays depuis 20
ans et jeard Larcher qui était
rapporteur du texte il y a 20 ans s'en
souvient nous avons régulièrement des
textes qui de manière un petit peu
insidieuse viennent impacter
l'aménagement du territoire ça a été
vrai cette année avec la loi allure ça a
été vrai avec la loi agricole ça a été
vrai avec la loi de finan et ce texte
fait partie de ces projets qui ont un
impact sur l'aménagement du territoire
je ne reviendrai pas naturellement sur
ce qu'a dit le rapporteur de la
commission remémy pointer qui a
excellemment présenté le point de vue de
notre commission je voudrais simplement
formuler quelques remarques madame la
ministre la première c'est que c'est le
troisème texte relatif aux collectivités
locales depuis le début de l'année nous
avons eu la loi relative aux métropoes
la loi relative aux régions dont nous
débattions encore hier après-midi et
puis ce texte et pour autant on ne voit
toujours pas quelle est la vision du
gouvernement en terme de collectivité
locale quels sont ses projets quelles
sont ses ambitions et j'espère que ce
débat permettra de nous éclairer et
d'ailleurs ce qui est assez original
c'est que le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui ne correspond plus à ce qui
était la volonté du gouvernement il y a
6 mois quand le projet de loi est passé
au Conseil des ministres au mois de juin
il y avait la volonté de supprimer les
départements et aujourd'hui j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure on a le
sentiment que ça n'est plus le cas je
pourrais aussi m'étonner si j'avais un
peu plus de temps du fait que l'on
supprime la clause générale de compét
alors que le gouvernement l'a rétabli il
y a tout juste un an je me limiterai
donc à faire quelques quelques remarques
premièrement il y a dans ce dans ce
texte dans ce projet de loi deux
dispositifs qui sont pour la commission
tout à fait inacceptables le premier
c'est la question du seuil de 20000
habitants et je je salue bien sûr le
travail de la commission des lois qui a
supprimé ce seuil parce qu'autant dans
certains cas ce seuil peut être
pertinent dans certains cas autres il
peut être même insuffisant autant
vouloir de manière générale l'appliquer
quels que soient les communes et quels
que soient les territoires ne me paraît
pas du tout opportun il y a dans le
département dont je suis élu comme dans
bien d'autres d'ailleurs des communautés
de communes qui sont encore autour de
5000 habitants je ne vois pas comment
d'un seul coup on peut marier quatre
communautés de communes et se retrouver
avec des communautés de communes qui ont
une une centaine de communes deuxième
point qui me paraît pas acceptable non
plus et sur lequel pour l'instant la
Commission n'a pas obtenu satisfaction
de la part de la commission des lois
c'est le caractère prescriptif des
schémas régionaux d'aménagement des
développement durable du territoire
madame la ministre votre collègue c'est
Goolen Royal devant la commission que
j'ai l'honneur de présider il y a
quelques jours qu'il y avait beaucoup
trop de schémas dans notre pays et qu'il
fallait arrêter de faire des schémas à
tout craint et bien je vous conseille
madame la ministre de suivre l'avis de
votre collègue et en tout cas de faire
en sorte que ce schéma ne soit pas
prescriptif parce que ce schéma qui va
venir se s'imposer au Scott j'étais déjà
contre le fait que les Scotts deviennent
prescriptifs et au
PLU en matière d'urbanisme notamment ça
n'est à mon avis pas une bonne chose
parce que je considère nous considérons
que l'urbanisme doit rester une
compétence du bloc communal et plus
particulièrement de la commune je
voudrais aussi évoquer une question que
j'ai déjà efffleuré tout à l'heure et
qui me paraît très importante on
aimerait connaître de manière claire et
précise le la position du Gouvernement
sur l'avenir des départements je
rappellerai que le Président de la
République en janvier à tu a dit qu'il
ne fallait pas toucher au conseils
généraux que le Premier ministre en
avril a dit qu'il fallait les supprimer
en 2020 puis en 2021 puis immédiatement
et puis cet été on nous a dit qu'il
fallait conserver les conseils généraux
en zone rurale sans que personne ne
sache ce qui'est un département rural on
nous a dit qu'il faudrait garder une
cinquantaine de conseils généraux sans
qu'on sache lesquels je pense qu'il est
temps d'avoir une clarification sur ce
point et sur ce sujet je voudrais dire
qu'autant je peux comprendre que l'on
supprime les conseils généraux dans des
zones urbaines comme ça a été fait dans
le département du Rhône autant dans des
zones rurales je pense que le rôle du
Conseil général est tout à fait
irremplaçable parce que ça n'est pas une
communauté de communes même de 20000
habitants qui pourra se substituer à cet
espace de solidarité indispensable sauf
à nous dire que ça n'est qu'un premier
pas pour aller ensuite vers les
communautés de communes à 50 60 70000 ou
100000 habitants j'ajouterais avant de
conclure un un regret c'est que ce texte
soit examiné sous le régime de la
procédure accéléré qui a été si décrié
par la gauche lorsqu'elle était dans
l'opposition je crois que c'est un texte
suffisamment important pour qu'on ait pu
espérer en la matière avoir plusieurs
lectures alors pour conclure je dirais
que effectivement ce texte est un texte
qui encore une fois concerne
l'aménagement du territoire que notre
commission entend prendre toute sa part
dans ce débat et que je crois que c'est
la vocation du Sénat de se positionner
tout particulièrement sur l'aménagement
du territoire et au sein du Sénat en
premier lieu de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire je vous
remercie
merci merci monsieur le Président la
parole est maintenant au président
Jean-Marie
Boel
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Madame et Monsieur le Ministre
mieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues 30 ans après les lois de
décentralisation de 82 nous attendions
un nouvel acte de la décentralisation et
le projet not se contente finalement de
rebattre les cartes sans nouveaux
transfert même si les travaux de la
commission des lois ont déjà permis
d'aller plus loin au moment euh où euh
vous-même monsieur le Président et le
bureau de notre assemblée veulent
renforcer le rôle de notre délégation
aux collectivité territoriale et à la
décentralisation il ne me paraîtrait pas
aberérrant sur des textes comme celui-là
que nous puissions disposer je crois que
c'était le cas par le passé d'un tempend
de parole en tant que tel d'autant plus
que c'est des questions sur lesquelles
et beaucoup de collègues qui sont depuis
longtemps dans cette délégation peuvent
en témoigner nous avons beaucoup
travaillé et même si nous ne sommes pas
sur le texte ça n'est pas notre rôle
nous sommes évidemment en amont de de
bien des réflexions qui aujourd'hui
apparaissent je voudrais simplement très
brièvement évoquer quelques principes
qui me paraissent des préalables à la
réussite de cette réforme premier
principe il est important de procéder à
une clarification précise des
compétences tout en poursuivant le
mouvement de décentralisation à cet
égard la suppression de la clause de
compétence générale appit plusieurs
revivrement plusieurs revivrements est
une sage décision les différentes
collectivités ne demandent pas un
élargissement massif de leurs
compétences ell souhait seulement que
ces compétences soient précisément
définies et qu'on les accompagne nos
ressources nécessaires les régions sei
ainsi confier la responsabilité de
définir une stratégie en matière de
développement économique j'y suis
favorable c'est là un enjeu majeur pour
permettre à nos territoires de déployer
tout leur potentiel et la création du
schéma régional de développement
économique accélérera cette dynamique
cependant et c'est le deuxième principe
il me semble indispensable de ne pas
instaurer la tutelle d'une collectivité
sur l'autre certes il faut avoir sur un
territoire donné pour une compétence
donnée une direction mais les
collectivités doivent travailler
ensemble en tant que partenaires et non
sous-traitant les acteurs locaux devrai
être ainsi associés à l'élaboration du
Schéma Régional de Développement
économique à travers la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique comme
nous le proposons avec mes collègues
centristes 3ème principe cette réforme
doit être conduite dans le respect des
collectivités existante et du principe
de libre administration la création des
grandes régions dans certaines le son
trop on le disait hier à redonner au
département toutes leur place en tant
qu'échelon de proximité si la réflexion
sur les départements d'après 2020 reste
à mener rien ne justifie à ce stade le
chifonage de leurs compétences il faut
saluer donc les amendements qui seront
proposés à la suite du travail en
commission dans un contexte budgétaire
difficile l'objectif de cette réforme
est de réduire les déficits publics on
connaît les chiffres pour les années à
venir on connaît aussi le risque d'un
effet récessif sur l'investissement et
je voudrais à cet égard saluer le
travail fait par plusieurs de nos
collègues de la délégation qui ont
récemment déposé une première partie
d'un rapport sur les effets justement de
ces baisses dotation aussi avant
d'asphixier les collectivités je
considère 4e principe peut-être plus
important que la mère des réformes reste
celle de l'État je suis convaincu que
dans son organisation propre l'État peut
encore trouver des ressources d'économie
pourquoi ne pas s'attaquer par exemple
au PO écrasant de la fonction publique
la question de la réglementation de
l'État applicable aux collectivités
local des normes également à
l'origine en 2013 de 1,2 milliard de
dépenses nouvelles non compensé doit
être posé notre délégation dotée d'un
nouveau pouvoir d'avis législatif en
tant siatelé et le premier
vice-président de la délégation monsieur
pointro d'ailleurs va animer un groupe
de travail sur ce sujet c'est très bien
c'est important enfin 5e et dernier
principe il convient de favoriser les
progrès de l'intercommunalité tout en
tout en prenant davantage en compte la
diversité des situations locales je
souscris à la montée en puissance des
intercommunalités partout et à leors
élargissement progressif vers la notion
de bassin de vie cependant alors que la
France vient tout juste d'achever sa
carte intercommunale il faut s'adapter à
la diversité de nos territoires
l'approche purement quantitative avec le
relèvement du seuil à 20000 habitants
n'est pas tenable et il faut vraiment
saluer sa suppression sortant des
sortons des logiques arithmétiques et
faisons au moins un peu et pourquoi pas
beaucoup ou confiance aux élus locaux en
définitive le texte proposé par le
gouvernement manque tout de même de
souffle et de vision mais notre Haute
Assemblée émanation des collectivités
locales a une responsabilité majeure
dans la réussite de cette réorganisation
aussi je ne doute pas mes chers
collègues que nous saurons inscrire nos
travaux dans une démarche partagée la
plus consensuelle possible pour
améliorer significativement ce projet de
loi dans l'intérêt bien compris de nos
territoires et de nos concitoyens
merci monsieur le Président
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Renand DC pour le groupe
écologiste
n'est pas en procédure accélérée vous le
noterez il a tout à fait raison vous
avez la parole mon chers collègue oui
oui oui oui mais il vous reste le
secrétaire d'État ils se raconteront les
choses
merci
bien vous avez minutes ça m'a pas
échappé monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président monsieur le ministre
messieurs et mesdames les les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous voilà
donc à l'OB de l'examen de la 3è loi de
la mandature sur le sujet de la réforme
territoriale bien conscient de la
difficulté à mener une telle réforme
territoriale ambitieuse pourtant
nécessaire dans un pays de plus en plus
paralysé par ses conservatismes je veux
commencer ici par rendre un sincère
hommage donc vous lui transmettrez à
Madame la Ministre Marie Lebranchu qui
ne ménage pas sa peine depuis 2012 pour
faire évoluer l'action publique dans une
France empêtrée non mais surtout
transmettez dans une France empêtrée
dans un millefeuille territorial qu'on
ne sait par quel bout entamer et une
confusion des responsabilités qu'on ne
sait comment démêler mais la méthode
employée par le gouvernement est-elle
satisfaisante et nous donnait-elle
toutes les chances de mener sereinement
ce débat si ce texte porte des avancées
nota sur lesquels je m'exprimerai plus
longuement d'ici quelques minutes il est
regrettable qu'il arrive en dernier nous
avons déjà pu le dire ici traiter des
métropoles en premier comportter un
risque de crispation pour la suite et
surtout avoir redéfini la carte des
région avant d'avoir une vision claire
de l'ensemble des nouvelles
responsabilités qui leur incombrait
était une erreur lourde de conséquence
nous le subissons aujourd'hui y compris
dans les incohérences de la carte
territoriale qui se précise sur la
méthode enfin la concomitence entre ce
projet de loi qui fait évoluer les
compétences des départements et la tenue
des élections département en mars
prochain n'est pas sans poser quelques
questions démocratiques comment en effet
faire campagne sur un projet
départemental proposer un contrat
démocratique avec les citoyens alors que
les compétences départementales ne sont
pas encore connues nous ne créons pas
ici Monsieur le Ministre les conditions
d'un renforcement de la démocratie
territoriale je rejoignais ici les
analyses de Rémi po mais qu'il se
rassure pour le reste nous divergeons
profondément sur le fond en effet quand
en octobre 2012 le président du Sénat
avait convoqué les états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale et que le
Président de la République qui débutait
son mandat y avait fait des
annoncesacieux je m'étais pris à rêver
d'une grande ambition décentralisatrice
pour notre pays tout juste 30 ans après
la première loi de faire les écologistes
ont cette vision ambitieuse de la
décentralisation et ont toujours été en
avant sur leur temps parce que nous
considérons que la gouvernance et
l'organisation territoriale sont les
clés de l'efficacité ou au contraire de
la défaillance des processus de décision
et de mise en œuvre des politiques
publiques nous prenons ainsi une
démocratie territoriale qui correspond à
la réalité de territoire de vie pas ceux
de la Révolution française où le cheval
et la marche à pied fondai ces
territoires nous sommes bien au 21e
siècle époque du transport public et de
la voiture individuelle où agglomération
et région sont les véritables espaces
vécus au quotidien sont les territoires
des coopérations associatives
universitaires et économiques en
cohérence avec le renforcement du couple
région intercommunalité qui est le cœur
de ce projet de loi et que nous
soutenons les écologistes prennent aussi
une décentralisation différenciée la
décentralisation à l'identique partout
ne peut pas être une bonne réponse parce
qu'on ne peut pas apporter des réponses
identiques à des situations différent
même si la Constitution de 1958 nous a
enfermé dans une décentralisation
décidée par le pouvoir central et
applicable à l'identique sur tout le
territoire le développement loi après
loi de statut particulierers lacse des
terir ultramarin ouvert la voie sans
oublier les statuts particuliers de
certaines des plus grandes villes de
France depuis la loi sur les métropoles
nous appelons donc au renforcement de
cette logique d'une décentralisation
s'adaptant à la diversité des
territoires nous en avons aussi parlé
hier pour l'Alsace et nous déposerons de
nombreux amendements en ce sens nous
serons attentifs madame la ministre à
vos propositions pour contourner ce
carcan constitutionnel d'un autre temps
malheureusement maintenu par le refus de
l'opposition nationale de s'engager pour
des raisons de calcul dans toute réforme
constitutionnelle pourtant nécessaire à
la modernisation de ce pays le présent
projet de loi présente des évolutions
qui vont selon nous dans le bon sens
tout particulièrement par la
responsabilité donnée aux régions
d'établir des schémas prescriptifs en
matière de développement économique et
d'aménagement du territoire vieille
proposition des écologistes
Marie-Christine Blandin en tant que
présidente de région le défendait déjà
en
1990 longtemps considéré sur ce point
comme de dangereuses utopistes et j'ai
quand même l'impression que certains ici
veulent encore revenir en arrière mais
nous commençons donc à avoir l'habitude
que l'histoire finisse par nous donner
raison partisan d'une décentralisation
reposant sur des régions fortes les
écologistes défendront le transfert aux
régions de compétences structurantes qui
relève de la planification de
l'aménagement du territoire parmi
lesqueles les compétences en matière de
transport nousendrons aussi un
élargissement de leurs compétences sur
le champ environnemental tant nous ne
pourrons plus demain construire des
schémas d'aménagement du territoire qui
n'intègrent pas précisément les enjeux
environnementaux des régions renforcées
des intercommunalités correspondant à
des bassins de vie et doté d'un projet
politique et non plus uniquement chargé
de gestion technique de compéten
mutualisé une organisation territoriale
fondée sur ce sur ces deux échelons
correspond à la vision écologiste de la
décentralisation elle est cohérente en
terme d'efficacité des politiques
publiques et lisible pour le citoyen
nous saluons donc le fait que ce projet
de loi témoigne également d'une ambition
gouvernementale de renforcer les
intercommunalités et nous le
soutiendrons en ce sens contre les
conservatismes et sans vouloir gâcher
votre réveillon madame la ministre je
crains malheureusement que vous nous
vous heurtiez en janvier à quelques
immobilismes qui trouvent ici
généralement quelques écho ainsi la
commission des Lois du Sénat a déjà fait
passer la compétence tourisme des
communautés de communes et des
communautés d'agglomoration de compéten
obligatoire à optionnel retirer la
possibilité aux EPCI de prendre la
gestion des ports relevant aujourd'hui
de la compétence des départements et
surtout à supprimer le relevant du seuil
de 20000 habitants par intercommunauté
mais que comme je n'ai que 13 minutes je
vais arrêter l'énumération mais on voit
bien la logique surtout surtout ne
touchons à rien ce pays va
magnifiquement bien l'action publique
est parfaitement coordonnée tout va bien
Madame la Ministre et tout
particulièrement revenons sur le
suffrage direct pour les élection des
conseillers communautaires un des grands
tabou de cette assemblée même s'il faut
noter même s'il faut noter et c'est
peut-être passé un peu trop inaperçu que
dans le rapport du sénateur Bertrand sur
dans son texte sur l'hyperruralité ce
tabou a été un peu briser je m'en
inspirerai d'ailleurs dans un des
amendements déposés mes chers collègues
pensez-vous vraiment tenable de
longtemps continuer à avoir des débats
au moment des élections municipales
centré sur le niveau communal alors que
les décisions principales qui concernent
les habitants des territoires sont
prises à l'échelon communautaire
arrêtons de passer le message aux
électeurs car leur vote finalement
n'influe que peu sur les vraies
décisions prises localement et que
finalement donc ils peuvent finalement
sans désintéressés ils ne sont pas DUP
et je peux témoigner qu'ils sont
demandeurs de ce débat à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité surtout s'ils n'habit
pas dans la ville centre enentendons les
certains je reviens maintenant à
l'avenir des départements dont la
disparition n'est plus à l'ordre du jour
méloignant du petit libre vert ce qui
prouve que les écologistes ont autant
que d'autres à l'écoute des territoires
je ne défendrai pas la suppression pur
et simple des conseils départementaux
j'ai l'occasion de développer ses
raisons dans deux interventions à cette
tribune d'une part aucune collectivité
ne veut exercer les compétences sociales
du département d'autre part la création
de méga région redonne son sens à
l'échelon départemental entre entre
région et intercommunalité certains
pourront remercier Emmanuel vas qui en
faisant aboutir la création de méga
région a sauveré les départements et
nous AV et nous avons donc bien compris
que la phrase sur la disparition des
départements à horizon 2020 n'était plus
d'actualité nous considérons toutefois
que si le département peut participer de
la solidarité territoriale et de la
cohésion sociale il n'est pas pertinent
de lui conserver d'autres compétences
qui n'entrent pas dans ce cadre ce qui
aurait pour conséquence non seulement
d'aggraver les difficultés financières
des départements mais aussi de remettre
de la confusion dans la tentative de
clarification des compétences contenu
dans ce projet de loi je pense
particulièrement au transport au
tourisme au développement économique et
j'espère vraiment que dans ce débat nous
serons chers collègues montrer qu'en
2015 nous ne fêterons pas dans cette
discussion les 200 ans de la chambre des
pirres le Sénat de la restauration au
regarde de ces éléments ce texte nous
satisfait donc partiellement sur le
volet répartition des compéten ou pu
mieux dire nous satisfaiser jusqu'à son
passage en commission qui a parfois tenu
à l'hommage du millefeuille tel qu'il
est servi au restaurant du Sénat
néanmoins le projet de loi initial reste
aussi insatisfaisant sur deux points sur
lequel porteront nombre des amendements
du groupe écologiste l'absence de
proposition de rénovation de la
démocratie locale d'une part j'en ai
déjà parlé et l'absence de dispositions
donnant des marges de manœuvre
financière aux collectivités concernant
le financement des politiques
décentralisées nous pouvons avoir de
réelles inquiétudes pour l'avenir je
pense particulièrement aux régions et à
leurs compétences large sur l'économie
ou les transports nous y reviendrons
évidemment plus en détail quand nous
examinerons les articles du texte mais
nous croyons que les régions devraient
bénéficier de ressources financières en
lien avec l'exercice de leurs
compétences par exemple sur les
transports nous proposerons de nouveau
l'instauration d'inversement transport
régional et nous aurons à cœur également
de creuser le sujet d'une taxe poids
lourd rég régionalisé ces recettes
seront nécessaires demain à la qualité
des infrastructures dans tous les
territoires et donc à la compétitivité
économique des territoire c'est un enjeu
majeur c'est aussi l'actualité à l'heure
où se prépare le licenciement des
salariés d'comov et la perte d'un outil
pourtant déjà payé les présidents de
région appellent aujourd'hui à la mise
en place de cette taxe poids lourd
régionalisée nous devons les entendre et
faire preuve ici d'initiative au service
d'une demande qui vient des territoires
et qui dépasse et qui dépasse
leséclivage politique plus globalement
et je crois que la plupart d'entre nous
en ont conscience notre pays a besoin
d'une réforme fiscale profonde et cette
réforme que les écologistes appellent de
leur vœux devrait s'attaquer aussi à la
fiscalité locale pensons ne serait-ce
qu'à la réforme des bases locatives pour
le calcul de la taxe d'habitation
véritable serpent de mer sur lequel rien
n'évolue cette réforme fiscale devrait
logiquement nous amener progressivement
vers une part réelle d'autonomie
financière des collectivités et donc en
premier lieu des régions
l'autre grande lacune du texte ne relève
pourtant pas du détail puisqu'il s'agit
ni plus ou moins de la démocratie les
écologieses ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse procéder à une réforme
territoriale sans l'accompagner d'une
réforme forte de la démocratie locale
donner des responsabilités au
collectivité local sans renforcer la
démocratie locale créer un déséquilibre
de fond nous avons des propositions
touchant deux échelons qui selon nous
sont l'armature en devenir de
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays région et intercommunauté je ne
reviens pas sur sur le suffrage direct
mais nous avons d'autres propositions
sur certaines d'entre elles bicamérisme
séparation exécutive délibérative par
exemple qui vont sans nul doute être
jugés par certains un peu exagérés nous
vous proposons néanmoins de ne pas
attendre que l'histoire nous donne
raison pour les adopter nous allons
gagner du temps nous voilà donc face à
ce qui sera probablement le dernier
grand texte de réforme territoriale de
cette mandature beaucoup d'amendements
et des heures de débat nous permettront
j'espère d'aboutir à des solutions
partagées allant dans le sens de
l'intérêt général notre pays a besoin
d'une réforme lisible et ambitieuse ce
serait à l'honneur du Sénat d'incarner
ce souffle et de ne pas apparaître comme
uniquement nostalgique des organisations
territoriales du passé et des situations
acquises c'est en tout cas dans cet état
d'esprit que le groupe écologiste
s'engage dans ce débat je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
Dantec la parole est de notre collègue
Christian Favier pour le groupe
communiste républicains et
citoyensz la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le secrétaire d'État
mes chers
collègues le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est le dernier volet
législatif d'un profond bouleversement
de nos institution sans que nous ayons
eu réellement le moyen d'en débattre de
débattre en tout cas des objectifs
d'ensemble débuté sous la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi le Big Bang territorial
se poursuit avec la même
cohérence un projet profondément libéral
a mis lieu des attentes fortement
exprimées par les élus en octobre 2012
au cours des états généraux de la
démocratie locale organisé ici même au
Sénat à cette bouillie législative
technocratique inaudible pour nos
citoyens ceci sonné en trois textes il
aura nous quitons l'hémicycle du Sénat
mais nous allons revenir bien entendu
plus largement sur l'ouverture de la
discussion autour de la nouvelle
organisation territoriale au Sénat c'est
tout de suite dans 24h Sénat le
journal bonsoir à tous et bien bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition de 24h Sénat
voici les titres ouverture des débats au
Sénat sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale la majorité veut défendre
le département cet échelon de proximité
cher au sénateur la droite proposera de
conserver les compétences que le projet
de loi initiale